everyone thank you so much for uh coming
today
uh I'm going to start off
our day today with a hearing on HB
153 requiring that two or more law
enforcement officers in each County
received training regarding animal
cruelty and with us this morning to
start things off is a sponsor of the
bill representative compa good
morning good morning Madam chair
committee members and thank you um for
the record my name is Barbara coma
representing belnap
7 um this bill has come about due to
some
issues um
with some animal cruelty cases and
people not being
educated um all this bill does is
require 20 20 law enforcement offices in
the
state to be receive
training through um the police
standards we I do have an amendment
forthcoming but OS has not finished it
yet uh couple of things that it's going
to add is uh would be an 8h hour course
approved by the New Hampshire police
standards and training
Council and a 2-hour refresher update
training every 3
years
um I don't think eight hours of training
in a subject
matter is a lot to ask from 20 law
enforcement officers of the state
it would be 10 people in the state Poli
State Police and one sheriff or Deputy
from each
County this is a training tool only it
doesn't constitute that they have to do
anything they're there as a
resource if
needed a lot of small towns and
communities do not H their local
enforcement does not understand the
animal cruelty laws of this state they
do not know what to look
for and this is not the only thing we're
mandating is
training there is no other
mandate in
here
so I don't understand why anyone would
be opposed to training and I am open for
questions any questions representative H
Haskins thank you madam chair good
morning is this working it is okay um I
wouldn't think this is very expensive
everything seems to get an FN these days
but wouldn't you think that that's not
going to be a heavy lift
financially uh thank you for the
question representative H Haskins and no
I don't think it's going to be a heavy
lift I mean they already have training
available this would just be an
additional course offered and only like
I said 20 law enforcement people in the
state would be required to take that
thank you you're welcome representative
viby so um how does this uh um how does
this bill relate to the uh requirement
this constitutional requirement for due
process how does well I think um with
the training right
because when you're talking about due
process are clarify are you talking
about SU going in in the taking of
animals I just want to be sure uh I'm
I'm talking about the the general right
that uh citizens have to expect that
when uh they are involved in the Le
become involved in the legal system for
any reason that uh their case will be
treated appropriately and correctly
according to the
law well thank you for clarifying that
and I think that this here with these
training courses
would actually help in the due process
because you would have PE uh folks that
are actually educated in the laws on our
books um and understanding what it
is um and what
cruelty is
because um and understand when it's okay
to remove animals I think that's
extremely important and I don't I think
we've seen instances in the state where
done more harm when people don't
understand um the particular animal
being uh taken this isn't just about
dogs and cats it's about livestock
too and we need people need to
understand
that representative
Miner thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking the
question
uh it seems to me that uh Animal Control
Officers in each of the towns uh would
be um fit for this responsibility
doesn't this seem to be an overlap with
uh with their duties uh thank you for
the question representative Miner um so
this does not interfere with the
ACO a lot of towns and rural areas do
not have acos it is left up to the local
police
department um I know in our my town we
do not have an
ACO um
and there was an incident um where local
law enforcement came in to take care of
um a situation with a
horse
and they thought they did the proper
thing and then the horse ended up being
right back in the same situation a
couple days
later um and the local law enforcement
really didn't understand um because it's
just not in their band you know it's not
what they study it's not what they're
used
to and then it took another 10
days of horses in high heat during the
very hot summer not being having good
access to
water representative Freeman did you
have a question and then represent did
Madam chair thank you but my question
was along the line of Representative
minor so I got my answer thank you thank
you representative
Howard thank you madam chair um I wonder
I and thanks for taking the question um
representative come talk um I wonder if
uh so how do you connect the dots
between training and action like and how
how do how what would be the way to tap
into this training by the police force
at
large uh thank you for the question uh
representative Howard
um there are several courses out there
the police standards would have the
final say on what the training would
look like however I think that some of
that would have to do with um how cases
are prosecuted and understanding that
aspect because a lot of times um it does
we fall down at the
prosecutor prosecutor level when when
dealing with these cases and I think a
good understanding and good training in
that would help because that way all the
eyes of Da and te's are crossed you have
any questions representative
King thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking questions are
you aware of any other precedent where
um in statute that the legislator
legislature has mandated specific
training uh thank you for the question
no I am
not represent
Scully thank you madam chair and um
thank you for you know putting forward
this bill I think it has Merit I my
question is um given that we're talking
about two officers in the county how
will you decide who in the county gets
trained and how would we make sure that
those trained people are known to be
trained and available to other cities
and towns in a
County uh thank you for the question um
and well the sheriff sheriffs in each
County we of which there are 10 would
get to decide which person wants they
should train okay and the state police
um I'm sure that different troops have
different jurisdictions in different
counties and they would get to select
one person um in each of those counties
um I'm not sure but at the sheriff's
level it would probably be pretty simple
to find out who's knowledgeable you just
called the sheriff's department in you
to find out how we would pass that on
from the state police down to the local
level I'm not sure but maybe it's
something that's posted uh through law
enforcement like I said this is not the
only thing that this is mandating is
that 20 people take a training course
eight- hour training course that's all
it's mandating it's not mandating
anything else but we need people we have
to start somewhere with
education okay presentative Bixby so
just as a matter of clarification s of
the the the way this would work in
practice is that uh if uh a if a town
that didn't have an
ACO uh had uh a call or had a a report
of some sort of animal cruelty then the
police department in that town could
call either the sheriff's office or the
state police and ask for assistance with
the case so that they could get it right
is that is that the way it would
generally work thank you for the
question represent Bixby and yes that is
the intent it's all would also be a
resource and maybe they're just the
person that's knowledgeable if the local
police department has a question so it
could be be a duel you know they could
have a reference but they could also
have someone um who could possibly
assist in that matter follow up followup
yep and how are the local police
departments going to know that this um
res
exists well I thank you again I think
that the the way that it would be done
is that um the state police uh whoever
the state police officer in the county
and the sheriff whoever in the sheriff's
office in each County could pass that
information on to the local law
enforcements in each County I don't
think that would be a heavy lift follow
up one more followup sure uh would it
make sense to add uh add to the
amendment a uh the the instruction that
that uh that information get
disseminated to local police
forces uh thank you representative Bixby
and I think that would be a great idea
thanks okay any other questions from the
committee representative
Barber yes thank you so much for your
testimony um is there currently a
Veterinary component involved in the
process at this time it seems to me that
um the training that we're asking um ex
is expansive across many different types
of animals um so I'm just curious if um
the training would be enough do we have
veterinarians that could be contracted
by um the county or
towns uh thank you for the question
represent barbar we do have uh laws
already on the books about the removal
of animals um this here is just a
training component would add the
training component into that
RSA for because a veterinarian is not a
law enforcement agency and they have
cannot go on to someone's property to
remove
animals it has to be done through law
enforcement okay any other questions
from the
committee thank you representative ktoa
for introducing this bill and we
appreciate uh your time in putting it
together thank you madam chair all right
at this time I'd like to call Sheriff
Bill Wright to the
microphone and your time is three
minutes that you've
requested there you
go good morning Madam chair and
committee members my name is is William
Wright I am the sheriff of bellnap
County and I'm also the president of the
New Hampshire Sheriff's Association I'm
here to testify in opposition of this
bill today I've served 27 years in New
Hampshire law enforcement I'm in my
third term as sheriff and uh I've I've
been at the sheriff's office now for
almost 20
years there's this bill has two primary
uh components to this uh the first part
is
training we agre agree that training is
important and that we should uh continue
to uh progress in the training I know
that each um recruit class so every
police officer that's been certified
through the state of New Hampshire has
attended a block of study uh through the
police academy on uh animal
cruelty Advanced Training of course is
is available um I don't believe that
it's available through the police
standards and training at this time so
we don't have a course that's readily
available for that although there are
some uh private classes that we can take
through Humane Societies such as that so
that's a component that we have to take
into consideration as to mandating
training that currently doesn't uh exist
and I know that uh director Skipper is
here and he'll he'll definitely correct
me if I'm wrong uh but I don't believe
that there's an actual Advanced course
on this uh which is something that I
think this bill is trying to
Target second is the component that
involves the requirement for the
sheriff's offices in New Hampshire State
Police to participate in potentially
assume uh animal cruelty cases and
investigations where local M
municipalities were either called there
to uh initially take the report or if
they don't have a local municipality uh
that that services that town then of
course the sheriff's offices and state
police would be arriving anyways so we
would just naturally assume those
cases based on our current legislation
under RSA 1045 it defines what the
primary duties of the Sheriff's Office
and what we're supposed to do on a daily
basis as relations to RSA
1045 most of my staff and most of the
staff that works for Sheriff's offices
across our state work dayshift because
that's where the pr primary duties uh
that require us to do there we all have
staff that are assigned to their duties
on a daily basis so having the
requirement of us uh to be available and
to assist local municipalities as a
requirement based on this law or this
bill that's proposed can create its own
uh challenges for us and Staffing in the
in the current St statutory duties that
we're required to
do RSA 104 col
6 also talks about other things that
Sheriff's offices are able to do which
is assist local municipalities as they
request we also have the ability to say
that we don't have Personnel available
or we don't have personnel that uh have
that education discipline or other uh
reasons that we might just not be able
to assist and that we would refer them
on so we already have an enabling bill
that allows us to assist local
departments we don't need an additional
Bill to tell us that we're required to
help or that we need to send somebody to
to assist in this some Sheriff's offices
don't even have investigative uh
deputies assigned to their departments
such as Coos they do no criminal work I
don't even and uh Sullivan County I
think does very little my organization I
have criminal investigators that I've
assigned to my organization uh which we
do help local departments when when it's
necessary this bill was not requested by
the New Hampshire uh Chiefs of police
which are the ones that would most
likely be calling for our assistance in
the first
place the primary concern of this bill
for us on the sheriff's Association side
is the Mandate for the Sheriff's offices
to to participate in the actual
investigation portions and to utilize
our resources to assist the M
municipalities uh for specific
investigations that could be timec
consuming And Timely and financially
strapping uh in in areas in which we do
not normally focus on so I believe at at
this point this is not a good PL a good
bill for the sheriff's offices to be
required to to provide that
function the legislation if if passed
would create more question for law
enforcement about who has the ultimate
responsibility for the investigation it
creates unfunded mandates for the
sheriff's offices in New Hampshire State
Police and it further creates the need
to establish investigator positions or
assignments within Sheriff's offices who
don't have investigators currently at
their
organizations the New Hampshire
Sheriff's Association Association is
comprised of 10 County Sheriffs and in
closing we respectfully request that
house bill 153 FN be voted inexpedient
to legislature I'll take questions thank
you representative Bixby uh one of the
issues that you mentioned was in terms
of resources uh at this at this point
the bill does not have uh any uh funding
mechanism if uh funding were made
available to cover the costs of this at
the county level would that uh change
your opinion of the
bill we would have to Define what the
the funding amount is and I'm not
talking about dollar amount I'm talking
about what that resource will be whether
it be an actual person that's hired to
specifically handle these types of cases
and to be utilized as that resource uh
and I don't have an answer for that U
followup uh if we were to amend the bill
would you be willing to work with us to
to um make it uh more uh more in line
with what you would can um perceive as a
possibility if this bill was designed
specifically to uh capture that we would
go to trainings and that we would have
people
trained then you probably not have any
opposition from the sheriff's
Association where we do have the uh
opposition is where it now requires us
to have somebody available and to assist
we don't always have those luxuries to
do that thank
you any other questions from the
committee representative Miner and then
ger thank you madam chair do you find
this bill to be excuse me timec
consuming on your on your part that this
that it really doesn't seem to be that
uh to me that there' be that many um uh
calls for your your help do you you do
you think it'll be very timec
consuming we don't know what kind of
calls we're going to get so it's always
a question uh if we look at a case
similar to what wolfboro had to deal
with back several years ago with a great
Dan that was a significant case with
significant time put into that with a
significant amount of resources could we
as sheriffs or State Police be required
to investigate or be participative
members in that and now included at a
county or state level uh for a Township
that could be uh very burdensome and let
us not forget that an investigation even
though that it starts and it closes it
doesn't end for us until the court
process is over and and all the appeals
processes and everything else that's
associated with it and the also the more
officers that you add to this um
investigative process opens us up for
more
liabilities thank you for that
representative gerana thank you madam
chair and thank you sir for taking my
question I understand there's always a
concern when responsibilities are added
through a form of a mandate you know
that there's a mission creep kind of
thing that happens and and that more and
more responsibilities might be added my
question has to do with in your
testimony uh you stated that the concern
is the
requirement uh that Sheriff's offices
would have to participate in and
potentially assume the primary roles in
these investigations and uh what I'm
wondering looking at the bill is I don't
see anything in the bill that says
anything other than someone would be
available uh to be able to assist I
don't see anything here that requires a
sheriff's office to take over a primary
role uh and and the phrase uh to be able
to respond and assist again I I don't
really read that as a as a hard and fast
mandate because if you don't have the
resources to
assist you can as you do now say we
don't have the resources to exist so
could you help me understand where you
see some type of hard and fast mandate
in the specific specific language of the
bill sure on line 13 where it says who
is able to respond and assist local law
enforcement agencies in that county with
any potential investigations on RSA 644
col 8 that right there is too ambiguous
for us to determine whether or not that
means what to what degree the assistance
is most of the towns and cities that
have Animal Control Officers are able to
handle these situations predominantly on
their own or with some assistance
although they they definitely Take the
Lead some of the smaller organizations
that have uh part-time police
departments or or um one officer type
shifts uh would rely on us a lot more
heavily to actually assume the
investigation once we're involved we're
going to take the responsibility of
making sure that we get to a finish on
these cases and a lot of times that
means that a local Department that
cannot afford to have that officer off
the street for any period of time uh
that burden gets pushed back up to
either the county or the state police is
how we view this bill so that wording
alone to that if it has to be in a
legislative process to say who's able to
respond and assist local law enforcement
then that's we consider that a mandate
that we would be expected to do what we
needed to do to come to resolve which
means investigate the the situation
there's there's just not enough in that
there would not be enough language in
that bill as it's written right now to
actually Define whose roles and
responsibilities it is to ensure that
this invest investigation came to
completion follow up thank you I
appreciate that and and would you be if
this bill were something that you know
we were going to work on more and you
were to assist us with would would it
help do you think to add some clarifying
language to the effect of as Staffing
allows for example uh because I I can
certainly understand uh that there are
times when these requests may come in
where it's not feasible for you to
provide that and that that per that
makes perfect sense to me so I'm
wondering if there's some way that the
language might be shaped in order to
recognize that there are times when
Staffing will not allow for the kind of
assistance so as a sheriff we want to we
want to take out as much ambiguity
ambiguity as we can and we want to make
sure that um language that says you know
as we have Staffing available or what
have you uh that can be interpreted and
then that can create its own issues
where once again we have investigations
that don't come the completion and that
and that's and I think representative
comptoire is trying to get to a point
where uh when an officer gets called to
a location it gets investigated they
utilize the appropriate resources come
up with the appropriate determination on
what to do with these animals and then
come to a conclusion uh whether it be
court process or or education piece um I
believe that there's a lot that can be
done at the at the County Attorney level
and at the Attorney General's level that
can be put in policy
as to how we're supposed to be doing our
job uh when it comes to these type of
Cruelty cases and uh more guidance on
that that that's not legislative process
but more of an administrative process
that can be changed and perfected as
necessary and direct us to the resources
that we need I don't believe that
legislation uh is should be mandated uh
for us to as sheriffs in New Hampshire
State Police to have to go and and
actually um assist in these manners
where we don't know if we're going to be
the lead we I would assume that it would
be uh if I got a call from a local
agency they wanted assistance uh it's
not just holding the door for them by
the time we get into this they're
probably going to step back and allow us
to continue to move forward with the
case which again is time and resources
and it's it's uh it's strapping that
that we we have
this thank you very much representative
King thank you madam chair thank you
sheriff for taking questions are you
aware of any um mandates that have been
created by the legislature in the past
um that are similar in not necessarily
nature but just the idea that the
legislator has mandated certain training
are you aware of anything sure RSA 106
uh which establishes the New Hampshire
police standards and training Council um
they've directed us through that to
attend certain trainings and then of
course through the PS is where uh we get
our directives from so yes in essence
there is followup followup y did you
find these mandates to be tenable or
untenable the mandates were tenable when
it comes to training so if this is if
this bill was solely about training and
that that we're asking for people to go
to
trainings we wouldn't have an argument
right now because we would send our
people the trainings of course we'd want
to Define what that training is is this
an 8 Hour online class put on by whoever
or is it through the police uh standards
and training Council which again I'm not
so sure that they have a current
Advanced course on this okay thank you
okay representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair thank you Sheriff Wright as
the loyal daughter of a sheriff I thank
you for your service now it seems to me
that you're the kind of guy I would want
to answer these calls so I if this is
going to be um within a department
somebody who has an inkling toward this
and they would be glad to take the
training the the problem exists the
animals are going to you know
occasionally have need of
intervention wouldn't we rather have
someone who has the training if you're
going to get the call perhaps
anyway yes of course we want uh thank
you thank you for recognizing me and um
we do want well-trained people we do
want the people who are passionate we
try to we try to as as department
leaders we try to negotiate our people
uh into areas of their passion because
we're going to have a better work
result mandating us to be participative
members and is where I find that this is
problematic like myself if I have
Personnel that have a passion for this
and I hear of an organization within my
community that needs
help I offer that assistance to that
Community now it's up to that that chief
officer whether or not they want to
accept the help or not which they make
that
determination but we most certainly make
it available to them and they can
utilize the service if they want but we
Sheriff me I direct what my Personnel do
and I and I know how to manage their
time and what we have work product so I
know the balance between what we're
required to do by RSA 104 and what we
can do by RSA 106 and this part right
here where um this bill would now add
another layer to this that's requiring
us to do a specific function which I
don't believe needs to needs to be there
each Sheriff has the ability and each uh
chief officer of every municipality has
the ability to uh offer assistance when
necessary so we already have these
enabling bills we don't need another
bill to require us to do something
specific where if I can offer people
then I do if I don't have the resources
then I don't offer it and I try to I try
to get them to another resource
thank you um Sheriff rright I have a
question and I'll get to yours as
well in the current Sheriff training or
police training that uh is required by
other
rsas do you receive training uh
regarding animal cruelty uh reports how
to report them uh what what animal
cruelty looks like uh any of that do you
do you get that kind of training in your
normal
training not so much who to report it to
because people report the crimes to us
so we're the ones that take the
information and and then either bring it
up to the criminal level of of
prosecution or we defer to other
organizations across our
state I'm not sure if that answers your
question okay
um like if if I had a question about an
uh animal Cru case um I might call uh
the state agriculture I might call the
State Vet I might call my local vet I
may uh call an ACO and ask them you know
who who to talk to or maybe they have
that expertise again I think that uh our
resources defining our resources could
be better and that we could again this
is something that could be built into
part of the Attorney General's manual to
where where do you go if you have um you
know an equin or or a swine issue or a
question U I can't tell you what a Sit
cow looks like unless it's absolutely
obvious well that's what the point of
this bill is is to make sure that the
folks in law enforcement do do know what
a sick cow looks like or what uh what
abuse looks like and um because we're
finding more and more as um reports are
are made uh that law enforcement
uh coming to these uh places where the
reports are being made U they are they
are unable to really tell what they're
looking
at and this is this is sort of a remedy
to try and get more people in law
enforcement to understand what it is
they are looking at I'm not so sure a
weekl long uh eight hour training or a
week-long training would would get us to
where we need to be for all the various
animals that people have but I can tell
you that given me a a resource book that
shows uh if you have ecoin issues or
that you have a question about it that I
can call this one specific number and
reach somebody and then get their uh
opinion whether it be they show up which
we've had investigations where people
actually show up and they take a look
again Dr Crawford the State Vet uh we if
we call his office uh we explain what we
have but sometimes we send photographs
down and then they'll make a
determination if they're going to send
an actual person person who is uh
certified to to identify that this is
actually what it is I think the burden
uh that's trying to be put on police as
to decide whether or not an animal is
sick or not uh without with with the
exceptions of obvious um issues it it I
think it becomes more of a a problem for
us that this is not our area of
expertise and and I don't think that you
can capture that in a in a short class
or something that we would think would
be
um acceptable to teach in in such a
short confined time frame and then again
it's resources what resources do we have
uh sending these officers away having
them go up and look at these animals
doing an
investigation again we we have people
that we call so so I think that we can
capture what the goal is is to get it
from time of call to time of prosecution
if it gets to that uh and the safety of
the animals in between that's where we
that's where it needs to be focused on
not a bill that requires me to go out
and do an investigation
thank you representative Penza and then
representative
Howard so I kind of have a followup to
representative Aaron um would you
believe that having some training in a
in a subject matter um one law
enforcement officer is better than
having no
training absolutely I think training is
key and and again we get the basics at
the Academy and then it's up to the the
uh leadership of the organization
whether they want to send
officers deputies to additional Advanced
trainings follow up
followup so the bill is specific
that you it's requiring one in one
sheriff in in one County and to have
that level of training which might just
be basic and it's assisting an
investigation not you guys taking over
the investigation and the specifics of
that training which I I think you have
concerns on that would be defined by
rules so you don't have to Define them
necessarily you can in the legislation
but would that make a difference well I
think if you're trying to create
legislation that requires a training
that you have to be defined of what
training it is that you're actually
looking for and and then we can start
honing it in to say and then what is the
participative member portion of this and
again I'm here because we're we're not
I'm not concerned about the training the
sheriff's Association is not concerned
about training because we've all
received the training we've all every
certified law enforcement officer and
all of us go to the same Academy state
police sheriff's office local police
City Town conservation we all go to the
same Police Academy we sit in the same
room and we go through the same uh
curriculum so we get this training
already that's part of your
certification process it's the ongoing
continued education that is that is open
to uh conversation whether or not we
want to require additional training
beyond that and then this this bill here
is of course saying that that that the
additional training would have to be
there so it' be more advanced training
well what Advanced Training do we want
to to make that be we have to Define
what it is that we're trying to
ascertain for a goal here and then and
then the idea of having that single
person in a county available to assist
um who is able to respond and assist the
local agencies that's the other sticking
point here is now you're requiring me to
uh who's able to respond and assist it
doesn't say who may uh go out and help
you know to what level of assistance it
is and this is where we run into our our
problems again I I agree that we want to
get these cases investigated we want to
we want to get the call get the animal
safe get them to the investigatory
portion to where we can get people uh
into court or educated depending on what
it is and then come to the absolute
resolve that's exactly what we want but
this bill right here requires a certain
group to do it and this and in that if
we have to be participative members in
it we rather send our person as a
resource and be able to not have to take
over the case and not have to because
again it it's it's too ambiguous for us
to make that determination based on this
and we know when legislation comes into
place it's very easy for or anybody to
say no that's your you know we ask for
your assistance and you're and what
we're asking for is you to take the case
and this is where the problems start
coming in and then and then the end
result is is that the animals lose and
that's not what we want so that is not
the goal representative Howard you're
next thank you madam chair um assuming
that that continuing training results in
Greater skills and maybe even
specialization as as this one hopefully
would be designed to do um does do you
think that having additional
skills um somehow disallows
prioritization of the of the of the um
assignment of ass of your assets or your
resources in your office do do you
understand my question so no could you
repeat that please so just BEC just to
put it really simply just because you
have the specialization inous doesn't
does it mean that that overrides other
specializations
and resources in at hand to the point
where you feel like it binds
you yeah so we have I mean we have
different Specialties I mean I'd love to
be able to assign somebody to be um you
know an animal cruelty expert I mean i'
I'd love to be able to utilize that as a
resource but I don't have that I I have
nine full-time employees that work for
me and out of those nine they're working
they they they work the same shift and
they're they're out working right now
and they're doing their statutory duties
now if we were to be asked by a local
organization within our uh County to
come down and assist with an
investigation again to what what degree
at what point do do I have the ability
to say I'll send them down to assist to
direct traffic but that's it or or are
we talking about we're assuming the
entire case too ambiguous language I
tell you at some point somebody will say
well it says to assist and the
assistance I was asking for was for you
to assume this in instigation and now
I've tied up my resources uh for that
investigation and and they may even have
somebody trained in it well everybody
gets trained in their organization
because we all have the same
certification so it's whether or not
we've gone above and beyond the training
uh to a different level ask a quick qua
sure um so so it sounds to me as if you
believe that this limits your choices
about how you assign your
employees well as written I believe that
it it makes it a requirement um that we
assist and and if if you're asking for
County to be involved as the the person
who is able to respond and
assist the question that I have is at
what point can I can I then go forward
and say I don't have a resource uh call
State and then the state going to turn
around and say no call County and then
I'm going to say ah you know this isn't
really our area like how does this work
what what's the remedy here and and I
think that this is problematic as it
relates to that so again we we as
Sheriff's Office we have well-defined
areas in which we operate in and this
only convolutes it even more and now
you're you're you're entertaining more
um or it's intertwining more
organizations where it doesn't need to
be we already have the ability if I need
help from State Police I give them a
call they either say yes we have
resources or not it's no different than
a local municipality calling me and
saying we need a resource are you
available yes we are or no we're not
it's um I I think that in this
legislation here in this bill if passed
it it would kind of require us to do
it okay I'm going to call on
representative Bixby then representative
King and then representative Penza oh
yeah I'm sorry uh representative Freeman
you're first then Bixby then King Madam
chair I appreciate that I know I'm
sitting low and I'm sitting over on the
side so should I jump up and down no no
no no I'm
sorry thank you Sheriff Wright for being
here I have I I have a two-part question
Madam if you'll indulge me and I'll make
it as quick as possible um first off uh
Sheriff right what is the normal
procedure right now if somebody calls
with the suspected case of animal
cruelty and you can give it to me in
like a thumbnail sketch sure ultimately
they would call into whatever dispatch
facility that local police department
has and the local police department
would dispatch or our dispatch would
actually like in belnap County our
dispatch would then dispatch out that
officer to go out and handle the call
okay and and this is the the second part
Madam chair thank you so that would that
would make that officer who responded to
the call the investigating officer is
that correct yes they would be the
primary responding officer okay did you
know that there's a law on the books
right now that says the investigating
officer must be accompanied by a vet
veterinarian um if they if they decide
to take livestock or any other the
animals from the from that household or
establishment no I was not aware of that
well I'd like to say I I appreciate the
New Hampshire F Bureau of federation
their letter because they actually
pointed out that statute to me that
there is a law on the books that says
that any investigating officer must have
and must be accompanied by a local
veterinarian or a state veterinarian in
order to take the animal from the
premises so again in bellnap County we
don't we don't do rural Patrol for uh
local towns so I don't I don't have have
any towns that I contract with or that
were their primary um responders so uh
we're a support service and and that's
that's we support them the best we can
so I don't I'm not familiar with that uh
that information in that law because
we're not the ones that are
predominantly getting the phone calls
for that and again we do get calls and
we do uh go out to assist so we we do
help local departments out thank
you represent vix yeah this is U
essentially a followup uh to
representative Freeman's point I just
want to make it uh be absolutely clear
that in terms of the responsibility for
the invest for the
investigation uh that fall does that
fall directly on the local uh law
enforcement agent in that in the town
where the or city where the um incident
is taking
place as of right now if they get the
call that is their their responsibility
yes thank you okay representative King
and then Penza thank you again Madam
chair I'm trying to wrap my head around
this bill because what I like to do is
try and figure out like an analogy and
I'm just curious if there's anything
analogous to this bill in terms of like
child abuse so you know if there's a res
if there's a call in a complaint about
child abuse law enforcement shows up you
know at the end of the day all they can
do is use their eyes and ears and you
know if there's a rug burn you eh it
doesn't look like child abuse but you
know if that if the child is in a really
bad condition you have to use your you
know your your professional judgment you
know to say Hey you know something needs
to be done here and I'm just curious do
we have mandates like what's in this
bill for child abuse or are we really
relying on just common sense here to
because it seems to me like if there's a
if there's a complaint about child abuse
the officer would use I would hope good
judgment in determining whether or not
they think there has been and then
ultimately it's going to go to doctors
pediatricians somebody who really
understands the issue about what is and
isn't child abuse and then that's at
that point it's more or less for the
courts you know to kind of figure out I
don't know it just seems kind of weird
the idea that law enforcement needs to
be you know professional in every little
possibility with child abuse or animal
cruelty or all these different things so
I guess my question is is there
something equiv to this for child abuse
or
not well I mean we have
mandatory processes when it comes to
child abuse or suspected child abuse so
and again we we reach out to other
resources so it's it's not always um the
sheriff's office or local PD that has to
has to deal with that stuff that's kind
of what I'm getting at with this entire
bill is that we have resources available
I don't know where this derives from I
don't again the chiefs of police aren't
aren't the ones asking for us to have to
do this and all that so I don't I don't
understand the the the process here
other than uh I I like the idea of more
training training is great right so so
our people training that's fine it's the
mandates that we have the problem the
the you know again who's able to respond
and assist that that's where we run into
our biggest problems here okay thank you
representative
Penza so language is so key and um I've
learned that a lot in my last term um
you keep saying mandate you keep saying
words like must um nowhere in the bill
does it say that it doesn't say must it
says who is able to assist there's no
there's no mandate no taking over an
investigation or anything like that so
where you can't read into a bill that
doesn't say that it it says able there's
no must there's no mandate so I believe
that this bill was initially designed to
to fix a problem in that that obviously
there's there's some form of a
problem and I can tell you that this
bill and the way it's written it's going
to come across as no we we're asking you
for assistance and it says who's able to
respond and assist local law enforcement
we want to pass this on to you and the
the perception is going to be that we're
going to have to take this over or that
it's going to create this this thing
that we don't come to resolve so I can
tell you there's a problem with this and
it's going to it's going to end up that
so I'm kind of forewarning you that this
is what's going to happen if this bill
portion continues to to be what we
believe to be a
mandate okay can I follow um yeah quick
followup we're we're running late and I
want to just move along here with all
due respect law doesn't work that way
perception doesn't matter it's exactly
what is written and that's how it will
be so that's where you push back if it
turned into something that is there
question represent so wouldn't that so
you follow the law so I don't understand
how you're going to read into something
because you wouldn't want that that's
how that's the your expertise and
fighting back so wouldn't that make a
difference in this no I think that the
law needs to be really defined as as
saying if if of what exactly the
expectations are and what the end result
is is going to be I think this is way
too ambiguous and I believe that it it
does create this question and and I
think we're going to the intent of this
uh it would be nice to have what what
the
intended portion of this is actually
spelled out in and puts it out to where
we need it to be so there isn't any
questions about it okay representative
Scully thank you madam chair and thank
you for being here your perspective is
very important um regarding the
language now it does as written right
now it says any potential investigation
and I take that you're assuming that
that could be a situation where this
whole investigation could be pushed onto
the sheriff's department um if that
language said um any uh helping with the
initial investigation does that would
that clarify the fact that you're just
there to give your quick opinion as to
what's going on here but the
responsibility of the subsequent
investigation remains with the agency
that you're
assisting more clarifying language is
always better for us so we know who the
one is going to be the one that's going
to be the ultimate responsibility of
this okay thank you thank you very much
appreciate your uh testimony this
morning and uh again I'm sorry we are uh
running a little late I know we had
another bill scheduled at 10:30 uh so we
we'll hopefully we can get through this
quickly uh uh Matt amuchi I believe it
is a m a t u ccii is that spelling
and you asked for three minutes yes
ma'am thank you madam chair thank you
Representatives um I'm here with the
state police and we are neutral to this
bill um I have a few comments and then
I'll be glad to answer any questions
that you may have um so police standards
and training currently provides training
during the police academy on
approximately 45 different investigative
taxs that include investigative
complaints of animal abuse or neglect
and use uh available resources to
resolve instances of animal cruelty uh
the state police is always willing to
assist local and county law enforcement
agencies with complex investigations
that require additional
resources um I'm unaware of any
additional training um that is currently
offered by uh pstc I'm sure director
Skipper can um clarify
that um criminal investigations
involving animal cruelty are conducted
like any other criminal investigation
ation um and to answer representative
King's uh question earlier uh there are
three trainings that are required
through uh police standards and training
uh it's a two-hour block um on implicit
bias two-hour block on ethics and two
hours on deescalation and then
um in addition to that is an additional
18 hours of inservice training um but it
isn't specified I am unaware of any
other
um specific crime that requires training
that is specific to that so for child
abuse or human trafficking um or any
other crimes against persons crimes
against property I'm unaware of any
specific training that's required um for
those particular crimes
okay uh I'm also unsure if it's
necessary to require a trooper from
every County need to have additional
training regarding animal cruelty
specifically uh again we have
investigators throughout the state um we
receive training um in
investigations
um in general but specifically um we we
may send investigators to different
trainings um but nothing specific to
animal cruelty okay thank you any
questions from the committee
representative Bixby uh if we chose to
uh amend this bill would you be willing
to uh would you or someone from your
department be willing to uh help assist
with the process to make sure that it's
consistent with um the state police's
practices and and um and uh abilities
yes thank
you any other questions from the
committee representa Scully thank you
madam chair do you have a state police
uh station in every
County not in every County we have um
troop stations throughout the state but
some of those troop stations are two
counties okay any other questions
representative Penza uh just quickly um
what is the numbers currently right now
um that are state troopers how many are
employed and are you guys at full
capacity and if you are at full capacity
what would that number be uh thank you
for the question uh when we are at full
capacity we have 362 sworn uh Troopers
currently we have 62 vacancies um which
is about 177% of our Force so to
mandate one Trooper Per County um could
potentially be problematic if that
Trooper is on
vacation we would be pulling troopers
from from other counties or other other
areas um major Crim is a good example
their house out of conquered they're
spread out throughout the state um we
pull resources wherever we need to um
regardless of what the case is if
there's a case and there's a local
agency um that requires assistance or is
asking for assistance we'll provide
whatever resources we have um with the
the larger more complex cases we pull
resources from all over the state so I
don't know that it's necessary to have
one Trooper designated Per County um
when they may be they may be stationed
in a different County than where they
reside um we also have transfers
Troopers move um within within the state
so um if that answers your
question quick followup yep sorry I know
I'm delaying time just quickly um just
like in the legislature we just you know
we get to pick what committees that we
on that were on do you feel as if um
based upon State Troopers that might
have an interest that there would be one
out of a county that would be interested
in maybe um taking this extra course and
because it's not in a sense a mandate it
would be one and it would be based upon
someone that's able so if they were on
vacation that's okay because there is a
basic training that you're already
getting um that this is offered you know
to basically 10 State Troopers that
there would be an interest somebody
might want to take that little extra bit
to be that the point person for the
county don't you think there would be
interest in that just like we have
interest in certain committees
here thank you for the question um I'm
I'm sure there would be interest um 10
is a big number 10 is a big number
we we require a lot of our of our
Troopers um they get pulled in a lot of
different directions um right now you
see the the State of the State if you
will in our highways and um the high
speeds and we're trying to combat that
and it seems like we're we're constantly
pulling Troopers to go do additional um
tasks whether that's becoming a drug
recognition expert or accident
reconstruction or there's a whole Litany
of additional
responsibilities um we're not opposed to
this bill um it's just requiring one in
every County could become problematic
and I agree that eight hours of train
training you don't become a subject
matter expert uh it's a little bit of
training training is good um we're all
for for training our our
personel but I think if you were to have
an 8 hour class you may get more than 10
or 20 in the entire State um some of
them may be local officers who have
jurisdiction in these cases that's who
should be going to these trainings as
well but to mandate um one Trooper in
every County I don't know if that solves
the the problem um if there is a problem
at
hand okay thank you for your testimony
appreciate it thank you um I call Lucy
Brown representing yourself and speaking
for two
minutes thank you good morning my name
is Lucy Brown I'm the second VP for the
new hampsh Farm Bureau vice president
for bnpp County and a young farmer board
member my husband and I are first
generation Farmers raising sheep and
beef cattle in our small town of new
Hampton we have all manners of livestock
owners from a thriving raw dairy farm to
hobbyists with pet goats and
equestrians our town is lucky enough
that our chief of police has some
background in livestock as his family
raises a beef steer and pigs on occasion
so when he has been called out to assess
animal cruelty complaints he has some
knowledge that he can rely on for
example is that cow starving or is it a
dairy cow that's in good condition and
lactating or is that horse starving and
neglected in a dirt lot with no grass or
is it on a very strict diet because of
Cushings or found dir disease well there
are well-meaning citizens there's a lot
of misinformation and we as a state
should be protecting our
agriculturalists by extending training
for law enforcement officers to have
some background on the Humane treatment
of livestock we can have effectively Pro
protect our livestock and their owners
from forc surrenders and scare tactics
that human societies use to bully owners
into relinquishing well cared for
Animals it's my hope that you all take
into consideration our Collective
experiences and thoughts on the matter
so that our small small farms can
continue to thrive in our
state thank you for your testimony any
questions from the
committee um I have a
question in your experience uh either
within Farm Bureau or you know just as a
in living in a rural community do you
feel that la enforcement in general be
it Sheriff's Office State Police local
law enforcement and I know that there
are some small town small some small
rural towns that don't even have a
police force so they maybe rely on state
troopers and so forth do you feel that
in general um that law
enforcement has an adequate background
in what animal cruelty looks like no
okay thank you our our chief although he
has some background in livestock there
have been a couple occasions where
concerned citizens have called in abuse
Char um thoughts of abuse and he's
actually referred to myself and other
Farmers with good standing in the
community to come and check and see if
it's something that need to be further
investigated or that we can just let it
lie so do you think having some extra
education would help law enforcement
especially in preparing whatever reports
they have to prepare PR personally I
believe that yes if they had additional
training but if they also had resources
of somebody that they could call to
investigate um if they just call a
regular vet that specializes in guinea
pigs and cats that vet is not going to
be adequate at assessing whether that
pig or that cow is in a safe condition
okay thank you any other
questions seeing none I appreciate your
time today thank you I will call Stacy
Ober from the American Kennel
Club who has asked for three minutes and
I believe you've already uh passed out
testimony to us thank you good morning
chair Erin uh members of the committee
my name is Stacy oer I am the New
England manager of government relations
for the American Kennel Club which is a
140 year old nonprofit widely recognized
for expertise in K9 Health breeding and
training and we represent more than
5,000 dog clubs across the country with
13 here in New Hampshire I did submit
written testimony so I thought I would
focus on some of the testimony that
you've heard uh this morning that I
might offer some uh additional comment
on you know my experience in covering
the six New England states has been that
you know everyone believes animals
deserve life in a safe caring and
healthy environment and that enforcing
our animal cruelty laws is very
important which is why AKC supports
House Bill
153 um because we see it as providing
some uniform training that's specific to
animal husbandry practices and Animal
Welfare which from my observation is
very much a team approach um which is
why I wanted to turn to the bill and
just note that as I read for instance
line
six and who is able to respond to and
assist local law enforcement agencies in
that county with any potential
investigation I kind of interpreted ass
Cy more as a consultation role um I also
wanted to flag that AKC has a Humane
fund which is a small grant that we
offer to domestic violence shelters and
it's specifically to afford them some
money to allow kennel space to allow a
victim of domestic violence for instance
to bring the family pet and the reason I
raised this is that I'm seeing more and
more States actually acknowledge the
relationship between animal cruelty and
domestic violence and so to have law
enforcement uh available with some
expertise and training around what
animal cruelty looks like these are
typical criminal uh offenses or calls
that I think law enforcement might get
for either um domestic violence or even
for drug crimes uh that's another
setting where in fact you will typically
see animal cruelty take place and so um
my read on the bill was really to have
law enforcement as a identifier where
there is animal cruelty and to then make
contact and consultation with those who
are responsible in that jurisdiction to
engage in um the investigation um last
we know that Humane officers do in fact
uh need training they need an
understanding of the Fourth Amendment so
that investigations and evidence
collection is done in a legal
uh Manner and there has been in New
England states that have adopted
required training for Humane officers
that for instance in Vermont is I is
defined as also including law
enforcement um there's required training
there um Massachusetts for instance
under the state police has specific
statutory language that has a special
unit where those state police officers
are uh very knowledgeable and conduct
all of the animal cruelty inves ation in
the state so I wanted to give you just
those two examples um and acknowledge
our support for a systematic uniform
approach to investigating animal cruelty
in the state thank you thank you
representative King thank you
representative thank you for coming here
today uh you brought up one of the
questions that I've been thinking about
in my head and that is um you know when
it comes to certain things um law
enforcement has like special police you
know we've got like the ATF or gambling
or you know we've got certain um sort of
you know regulatory police that like
they're just Specialists that's all they
do um do you think that would be and
then you also mentioned that other
states have things like that for animal
cruelty do you think that would be a
better method to go about instead of
having you know just the local state
police or local County Sheriff do that
why not just have you know some actual
like Specialists that that is like all
they do is animal cruelty and then yeah
they might not be in every County but
maybe they're based in conquered and
then when there's a call they can drive
to the the nether regions of the state
to to get there I mean would that be a
better method do you think I think
that's why some states have chosen to do
it that had the resources to do it that
way because um Prosecuting an animal
cruelty case is not an easy thing to do
you have to provide the appropriate
evidence it has to be timely evidence um
if any part of the search warrant was
conducted in an illegal way that
evidence gets thrown out so there is
some I think benefit from having
individuals who are consistent you know
and have the training and are
consistently uh facing these cases and
know how to deal with them so thank you
okay thank you for your testimony this
morning I'm going to call uh Kurt
aronburg from Humane Society United
States needed uh ask for two minutes to
speak
it off turned it off hi I'm Kurt
aronberg I'm the uh New Hampshire
director for the Humane Society of the
United
States uh thank you for allowing me to
speak I
uh along with the uh sponsor of this
bill serve on the governor's Commission
on the Humane treatment of
animals um the commission has had and I
speak for my myself here not the
commission but the commission has
had discussions over a couple of
years the need
for uh GA almost a guaranteed for lack
of a better term right now response to
an animal cruelty call and my my concern
as representing the animals in New
Hampshire is that if an animal is is the
victim of Cruelty and a call is made to
that local police department that
someone in law enforcement with
knowledge of how to deal with that case
in response not necessarily further down
the road and investigation Etc that
would be great all this talk about a
special unit we'd be all for that but
currently there there are animals in the
state that suffer cruelty without any
means for their their ability to be uh
uh alleviated of that suffering by law
enforcement so what we're for this
bill um it's it's certainly imperfect
and needs Amendment
but the
overall immediate need for the animals
in the
state is whether they're on a farm or in
a
home uh someone to respond immediately
who can assess the situation and take
action and I think that needs to be said
here today and I think that's the
direction this committee uh needs to go
in to protect the animals thanks thank
you questions representative
ruber thank you madam chair uh thank you
for your testimony you said the bill
you're supportive of this bill but uh
you mentioned it needs some amendments
can you clarify a little bit what sort
of modification you think would make
this bill even stronger well you
know my understanding is you can make
you can amend the bill to start all over
uh and but I mean my comments speak for
themselves I
think I believe certainly investigations
are very
important
but listening to the objections of law
enforcement on this um it seems like we
could do something immediately that
would take care of the response
situation and not and and
uh that would be my my first
concern
okay okay thank you thank you for your
testimony appreciate it um our last pink
card is from John
sippa and
um you have requested five minutes I
hope you can make it less because we are
running very late
um thank you madam chair thank you uh
all uh my name is John skippa I am the
director of New Hampshire police
standards and training I've been a
police officer in the state of New
Hampshire for about 40 years now uh and
I can tell you that uh during the course
of my career uh while these uh types of
cases animal cruelty cases uh
I did have a couple of few but the
number of them are are not uh a lot
right uh I was also fortunate enough to
be the chief of the stratum police
department and so the New Hampshire SPCA
was literally right down the street from
our station so we would rely on them a
lot for these types of
Investigations while sitting here
listening to the other folks that were
providing testimony I checked that I was
in favor of this but really I'm kind of
neutral and I'm here to just offer some
information my first observation is that
this bill really cuts across two
different issues the first one is
operational and you heard the sheriff
and you heard the captain from the state
police talk about some of the concerns
they have about the
operational of the way this bill is
written and I'm not really here to uh
discuss that other than to say that I do
agree with both the the sheriff and the
captain that there would be some some
operational ambiguity there that
probably needs to be cleaned up I think
more importantly I'm here to talk about
the training
uh I can tell you that uh listening to
uh representative Barbour uh relative to
recognizing that these are complex cases
that that need both training for
investigative purposes and for
prosecutorial purposes as well um uh
representative King you you were spot on
uh an operational way to address this in
my opinion would be to create a
Statewide task force uh we have task
force uh operation for a bunch of other
different uh topic areas investigative
areas to include crash investigation uh
drug investigations uh gun
investigations and so uh there clearly
is uh a way to put this into operational
um it put it into operations by way of a
task force that task force comes under
uh agriculture I don't know does it come
under State Police or Department of
Safety I don't know but I think that
would be the way to to do that I think
also the way this bill is written is
that it's cutting out about 3,000 cops
uh that uh and I I apologize I cannot
see your name placard but the
representative spoke to uh some folks uh
that are in law enforcement that would
have an interest in this particular
topic and I can tell you uh teaching at
the police academy we see people from
all walks of life come to be police
officers and many of them are gentlemen
Farmers quite frankly lady farmers that
come in and they have a extensive amount
of background uh with regard to dealing
with uh farm animals uh again very
specific and very different than uh
dealing with a household pet a dog or a
cat right um the way the bill is written
it's really just kind of you know we
want the sheriffs to receive the
training and we want the state police to
receive the training but uh it it might
it might be hoov this this committee to
look at uh making this available to
anybody that's in law enforcement that
has an interest and then creating a task
force to do
that the real reason I'm here is uh to
speak to the development of the training
and the bill suggests that the training
will be provided by New Hampshire police
standards and training uh in the short
time that I've been the director I've
been asked to do a bunch of extra things
that we didn't do before I was appointed
and I was uh always ready to say yes we
can do this but I never asked for money
and I learned that that we can do these
things but it does cost money uh we
certainly can rely on different partners
within the state of New Hampshire to
number one identify what the problem is
right now why are we having why is this
bill in front of all of you uh what what
are we trying to solve so we need to
figure out exactly what we're trying to
solve uh work with subject matter
experts to identify those learning goals
and objectives and then work with the
subject matter experts to build out a
block of instruction to address the
shortfalls that we're seeing right now
uh that may cost money uh and I would
need uh the um some money to be uh
provided in order for us to uh make sure
that we can cover any costs that are
incurred uh we would stand ready to work
with subject experts to put this uh
training together and to deliver it uh
but to that end
uh th this clearly is uh something that
has uh caused some issues that need to
be addressed We Stand ready at police
standard and training to do what we can
to provide that training uh to New
Hampshire law enforcement uh to make
sure that we're taking care of these
animals that are being abused and I
stand ready for any questions that this
committee might
have thank you Mr Skipper um I have a
question so far as uh your your present
training for or law enforcement to what
extent Does it include how to identify
uh issues of animal cruelty uh how to
report it um any anything in specific
having to do with the animal cruelty
statutes and enforcing those statutes
thank you for that question Madam uh it
is a very cursory toour block of
instruction that is given to every
police recruit uh that goes through the
police academy here in New Hampshire
we're fortunate that every police
officer and the sheriff and the captain
both spoke to it we have a single Police
Academy every single cop in the state of
New Hampshire receives the exact same
training uh to that end it's a two-hour
block uh it is very cursory it does
speak to uh the law that uh uh
representative Freeman had brought up
relative to uh you know police officers
having to bring a vet for know farm
animal um but it really just kind of
broaches a topic and then it points
those police officers to resources that
they can call uh it does not really dive
into the nitty-gritty of conducting an
uh animal cruelty investigation thank
you representative Bixby okay um so I
think that we've pretty we've covered a
lot of the territory in uh and I think
that your your testimony is really good
in terms of pointing to where we need to
head with this I think it definitely
needs an amendment and I was wondering
if you'd be available to help us put put
work on that Amendment so that we get
what it needs to uh for you to be able
to put a uh training course together uh
thank you sir and uh certainly We Stand
ready to assist uh in any way that we
can thank you thank you represent
Penza um thank you representative Bixby
uh thank you for taking my question um I
was just going to ask the same thing in
regards with the amendment piece but my
other question would be um in regards
when you said having it to law
enforcement would you also want maybe
those numbers decreased um from the
state trooper that was talking saying
you know 10 might be too much especially
um where they're at um capacity and num
you know or not at full capacity of
numbers like bringing that down if we
were going to have specific in there
from 10 to five those types of things um
if we wanted to get specific in there
besides just opening it up to full law
enforcement would you be amendable to
those types of changes thank you madam
for the question uh I think from an
operational point of view I would rely
on my partners I would rely on the chief
I would rely on I checked that the
sheriff uh rely on the captain and and
New Hampshire Chiefs to to Really weigh
in on that I think something that's
Global that needs to be also considered
is that uh there is vacancy rates that
the captain spoke to but those vacancy
rates are uh anecdotally across the
state right now and so uh what we find
is that when when agencies are underst
staffed it's more difficult for those
agencies to send their people to
training I anticipate just based on the
the notion that this
is these cases are like drug cases
they're they're pretty in-depth you
really have to know what you're talking
about and you have to have a lot of
subject matter experts kind of taking
part in these things I I don't
anticipate that this training would be
less than a week long quite frankly uh
to deal with you know uh all of the farm
animals that could be involved with this
and domestic animals as well so uh I
would certainly defer to uh my partners
with regard to whether there should be
any numbers in here or whether it should
speak more to the notion of uh creating
a Statewide task force that's managed by
and then fill in the blank uh that could
uh and then we could we could get uh
police officers Troopers uh Deputy
sheriffs that are interested in this
topic area and have a lot of subject
matter expert they they're GNA they're
going to uh come to this right if you
build it they will come and I do think
that it opens the pool of candidates if
you just kind of you know instead of
identifying sheriffs and and State
Police really kind of open it up um and
I think that might be an alternative
consideration to what's in front of us
today okay would you consider perhaps um
rather than a two-hour
cursory instruction that's given to all
law
enforcement that that be expanded to be
a little bit more in depth uh so that
all law enforcement has adequate
training in how to identify how to
report how to do whatever they need to
do uh within the law enforcement
capacity uh in in animal cruelty cases
uh thank you for that question Madam uh
presently the New Hampshire Police
Academy is 16 weeks in length uh We've
engaged the services of uh outside vent
to conduct a job task analysis for
police officers first year to fifth year
with regard to those things that they
really need to know when they exit the
academy uh that uh survey and uh data
Gathering is is happening as we speak uh
we anticipate that the length of the
academy will probably need to be
expanded uh we are a little bit under
the national average in terms of time
spent at the police academy and I can
tell you for a topic that is as
important as this one uh there are about
120 other topics that are equally
important that those police officers
have to uh receive training on and uh we
are fighting uh the these different
entities are fighting for uh an hour uh
here and there uh and so we really have
to rely on the data that's going to be
collected through the job task analysis
for us to really uh dial down and look
at how we um provide value to the
recruit as they go through the academy
make sure that we're touching on all of
those things they need to know am I
opposed to expanding that training no uh
not at all uh and that would be
notwithstanding the fact that we need
may need to expand training in other
areas as well so does law enforcement
already engage in say like continuing
education where they have to get you
know certain hours of training to qu a
refresh whatever um what about adding uh
course and continuing education for
animal cruelty issues thank you for that
question Madam uh the captain spoke to
the annual inservice training
requirements that we have now uh
presently we have 24 hours of inservice
training that is required every year
plus an extra four hours of use of force
training uh of those 24 hours of
continuing education that's required
annually for the police officer to
maintain their
certification uh they are required to
complete what we call the three twos the
three twos are ethics deescalation and
uh cultural uh uh sensitivity uh bias
training and procedural Justice uh each
one of those blocks of instruction is
two hours in length uh and then we also
have one hour that is required for every
police officer to uh take uh regarding
um post-traumatic stress syndrome and so
uh the remaining hours can be any hour
that the chief executive law enforcement
officer sees fit for their agency uh
I'll give you an example I was a police
officer in Ry uh we would uh enforce a a
fair number of fishing game laws because
we were right on the beach people were
taking Lobsters by hand and so training
in that area might serve that Community
right uh maybe a different Community
might want to Center their uh their
training on something different
uh that could be considered mandatory
training uh certainly would have to be
captured by either statute or um uh
through administrative rule uh there
again uh to the captain's point you know
there's there's so many different topics
that police officers have to stay on top
of throughout their career um that uh
you know are we going to see required
training on just a whole number of
topics that will come out I don't know
uh but certainly that that could be
considered a venue to do it thank you
any other questions representative
wheeler thank you madam chair thank you
director skipper for taking my question
just to these are great ideas but to
drill down on what you said in your
testimony about the monies your
testimony is that the monies don't exist
right now for the trainings and you
would have to get that money allocated
to you by the finance committee thank
you for the question representative
wheeler and that is correct I just want
to make sure that uh financially uh If
This Were to pass that uh financially
and operationally from my point of view
I would be able to engage the services
of those subject matter experts I don't
know what if any costs might be provided
uh or or necessitated to to put this
together thank you thank you any other
questions from the committee representa
Scully thank you madam chair um are you
aware of any New Hampshire Statewide
task force we have now for law en
enforcement and um is it considered a
success that
approach uh thank you for the question
representative Scully yes there are a
number of task forces uh that uh exist
in the in the State uh an excellent
example is the iak task force uh those
are uh police officers that are
specially trained in um uh finding
investigating and Prosecuting uh people
who uh exploit children through uh uh
internet uh pornography uh they are uh
Statewide they have uh resources that
are specific to their mission uh
Regional uh crash investigation units
are set up throughout the state those
can be uh set up by uh local agencies in
an area uh by County uh the state police
has a number of specialized units major
crime unit their drug uh narcotic
Investigation Unit um the uh impaired
driving unit that that does a lot of
enforcement in the area of uh impaired
drivers drunk drivers so the the model
of using task forces are not unusual to
New Hampshire law enforcement uh we are
very lucky in this state that uh
agencies work collaboratively throughout
the state and and I see that as a as a a
way that maybe you could make this
operational thank you you're welcome any
other questions thank you very much for
your testimony this after this morning
thank you and um I'd like the blue sheet
there's a blue sheet up on the desk up
there that has uh all the folks who
signed in in support and in opposition
for this bill in this
hearing yeah okay would anybody else
like to speak on this bill before I
close the
hearing seeing none
I'm going to um so we had uh one person
sign in favor of this bill I'm going to
hand this to the
clerk and uh online we had
um 10 people in support and one person
in
opposition for uh HB 153 and with that
I'm going to close the hearing on uh
hb13 and I appreciate everybody's time
and attention and my sincere AP
apologies for you all of you folks who
are waiting for
hp215 uh requiring a landfill permit we
are going to open that hearing
now uh for HB 215 uh requiring a
landfill permit applicant to submit a
report listing potential harms and
benefits of the project I will have the
sponsor of the bill uh um introduce the
bill to the committee and then we will
take uh a few folks we'll go till
noon uh and then I will recess until
later today so we'll see whatever we can
get through between now and then and I
will hand it over now to representative
ger to introduce our bill thank you
thank you madam chair honorable
colleagues uh for the record my name is
Nick gerana I represent chesher district
15 that's Chesterfield Hinsdale Keen
boards 1 3 through five um Sur Walpole
and
westerland I have uh circulated uh my a
copy of my written testimony uh which I
amended uh I appreciate the chair
sending out a copy of it yesterday I
made some some brief uh changes and so I
I recirculated
that under current statute public
benefit is defined in very narrow terms
does the proposed solid waste facility
contribute to the state Solid Waste
Management goals and does it meet a need
for capacity in the state what current
statute does not do and what hb25 seeks
to do is cast our decisionmaking in
terms of net public benefit none of us
in our personal lives makes important
Decisions by drawing up a one-sided list
of Pros we do not consider the possible
benefits of buying an expensive luxury
vehicle uh instead we divide The Ledger
into two columns we weigh the possible
benefits against the potential harms or
disadvantages we weigh the pros and cons
why on Earth would we not do the same
thing when we are considering whether or
not to site a landfill that will impact
the community for
Generations hb25 does three things first
it requires applicants for permits to
operate Solid Waste facilities to hire
an independent third party to conduct an
assessment of the potential benefits and
potential harms associated with
operating a facility in a particular
location second it states explicitly
that an applicant cannot combine
multiple projects as they make their
case for potential benefits for example
one could not use the possibility of
opening a recycling center in location B
to support the case for the potential
benefits of a landfill in location a the
project uh a location needs to be
evaluated on its own Merit
and third hp215 would more precisely
Define the term capacity need in statute
to say that there is a need an applicant
must demonstrate that there will be a
projected capacity shortfall in the
state for at least half the permitted
period of the
facility I will concentrate my comments
on the first of these three changes but
I am of course happy to take questions
on the other
two since the late 1960s the National
Environmental Policy act has required
environmental impact statements as part
of the process of reviewing major
government projects such as
highways each project proposed must
include an environmental impact
statement that addresses in detail the
social economic and environmental
conditions in a proposed location and
the potential harms that might be
incurred as the American Bar Association
explains these statements are quote
meant to be a comprehensive
decision-making tool for federal state
and local policy makers and to inform
the public about proposed projects that
could affect the environment end quote
in addition to potential impacts on the
environment for example protected
waterways local animal habitat Etc an
environmental impact statement must also
address quote social and economical
impacts to local communities including
housing stock business property values
in consideration of Aesthetics and noise
uh expected end quote 16 states have
Environmental Protection acts that
require similar environmental impact
statements I want to be clear to the
committee hb25 does not propose that New
Hampshire pass a similar environmental
statute I use these examples uh of these
federal and state statutes to show that
the methodologies have long existed to
do the work that is required in this
bill New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services does not have to
reinvent the wheel they have more than
five Decades of state and federal
practice to draw on as they draft the
rules and determine the appropriate
methodology for carrying out net public
benefit
analysis I would like to give one very
specific example from de's own work
recently presented to this
committee the state's Chief aquatic
biologist told the committee that the
presence of invasive aquatic species in
New Hampshire Lakes can lower property
values in the area by about 10 to 13
% this is one very specific data point
uh that is a perfect example of the kind
of information that Dees can use in its
consideration of net benefit some of the
potential harms listed in HB 2115 are
easily Quantified in terms of potential
economic impact like property values and
increased wear on roads others are
clearly tangible and easy to identify
even if they are harder to place a
precise dollar value on
such as impact on Recreation tourism and
Wildlife all however are vital to the
quality of life in our communities and
all have been part of the equation for
determining environmental impact at the
state and federal uh levels for
decades it is important to point out
that this is not just about
Dees above I cited the American Bar
association's statement that
environmental impact statements serve as
a tool both to influence policymaking
processes and to form the public when a
company applies for a permit to operate
a solid waste facility they have the
financial resources to hire Consultants
to produce reports that make their case
in the best possible light potential
host communities rarely have comparable
resources to investigate the potential
harms that their residents may have to
live with literally for
Generations the kind of assessment
required in this bill would become part
of the public record and give our
constituents all the information to
which they are entitled about projects
that are so consequential for their
communities the committee may hear
testimony at some point that this bill
is somehow unfair to business let's be
clear one of the major players in the
solid waste industry in New Hampshire
has a net worth of more than7 billion
dollar as of just a few days ago and
another has a net worth of more than $85
billion cassella Waste Systems paid the
state of M $35 million for the right to
operate a state-owned facility at
Juniper Ridge uh in that state these
companies are asking for the right to
operate extraordinarily lucrative
businesses in our communities the added
cost of maybe
$50,000 to assure the state and
potential host communities that they can
provide a genuine public benefit while
making enormous profits is not too much
to ask I thank you for your time and
consideration and and I'm happy to
answer questions thank you
representative
gerana um we have questions from the
committee representative Miner and then
representative Howard please come sit
down thank you m mam chairman thank you
for your
testimony am I clear uh when I say that
as of now there's no impact statement
that's that that's needed to be uh filed
by these um
um trash
companies thank you for the question
right now the question uh about what
constitutes benefit is based on what I
pointed out in my testimony a couple of
things does it uh help the state meet
its solid waste needs and does it uh
meet a capacity needs so that's the
question about benefit they certainly do
have to you there are air quality
permits there are water quality permits
there are all kinds of sighting
requirements that do have to be
addressed uh what this bill specifically
addresses is how we Define a benefit and
right now the way we def finded benefit
and statute does not require the
applicant to demonstrate that in a
balance between potential harms and
potential benefits that one outweighs
the other I understand thank you thank
you representative
Howard thank you madam chair um is there
a risk of inherent in having the um
organization that is wanting to put
making the application also make the
report of the benefits and and and
costs thank you representative Howard uh
yes and and this Bill gets at that by
requiring that it be a third party that
is is contracted to do this work we uh
certainly I would have a concern and and
would have never proposed a bill that
would say that we would ask the
applicant to provide that themselves but
this would require an independent third
party to do that work uh and Dees is
very familiar with the landscape of
consultants in this area and and would
be able to uh you know verify that it is
a legitimate independent third party
representative King thank you madam
chair thank you for being here today um
our current governor has recently uh
signaled a willingness to put the kibos
on uh a new landfill up north do you see
there being any executive action
possibly taken that could make your bill
moot in any way thank you for your
question representative uh first of all
I want to applaud the governor for her
statement please I I I would say that uh
we should not be discussing any
particular project uh I would rather
keep our comments regarding uh any
particular project any any landfill
project uh being considered in the state
so please let's not discuss any specific
projects in the works thank you madam
chair um that I my answer Remains the
Same in the sense that no I don't I
don't believe executive actions in any
case
uh would have an impact on what I'm
asking to do here this is not about any
one project this is saying that when we
are citing landfills our current process
is inadequate so whether we're citing
one within the next five or 10 years or
we're citing one 20 or 30 years from now
uh this is a process that needs to be
redefined I have a question and so far
as would you consider then rather than
the applicant
requesting or uh submitting
uh some cost benefit analysis or benefit
analysis that uh it would be our agency
Dees that would contract a third party
an independent bunch of eyes to take a
look at a
particular um project and and come up
with that cost benefit analysis uh thank
you madam chair I think that's an
excellent question if there were an
amendment that you know made the
applicant financially responsible still
for paying for for that study stud uh I
think that's an excellent suggestion
okay thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much oh was there one I'm sorry I didn't
see your hand representative Scully
pardon me I'll put it a little farther
this way thank you madam chair um so I
assume that if this law is passed it's
going to require the whole a whole set
of new rules to be created for Dees for
evaluating these um
projects thank you representative yes
that is that is if this passes Dees will
have to uh adjust the rules they'll have
to come up with new rules governing
exactly how this process would work uh
and the the bill is designed not to
micromanage to dictate uh processes or
methodologies uh but to allow Dees to
use their judgment and and yes sir they
would do that through writing rules
thank you representative
Penza just a quick question um
clarifying are you familiar with um
there was a 2023 uh state supreme court
decision that basically said that our
statute on this is vague and um it
needed to be made more sensible and in
with that um is this part of the reason
why this bill has been put
in is that with reference to uh defining
need correct yes thank you
representative yes that's important and
and that part of this bill is in
response to uh Supreme Court decision uh
which that Dees uh has within our
statutes current currently significant
latitude to Define need right so if we
say that we have a capacity need well
who's to to say what need is uh yes and
this bill is meant to uh as far as I'm
concerned put the legislature in the
position that we should be in in
clarifying statute uh rather than having
it so loosely defined and to say which I
believe is reasonable that need should
mean that uh there is capacity need for
at least half of the lifetime of a
permitted
facility yeah representative
guber M thank you madam chair um the
just to clarify need um or you just
discussed about for half of the period
that they would be permitted that's
assuming the need is for the State of
New Hampshire not neighboring states is
that clear that correct thank you very
much representative exactly I'm glad
that you asked that question statute
requires need to be calculated right now
based on New Hampshire solid waste needs
not the region and as as we've talked
about a lot we have become a magnet for
trash from around the region because our
regulations are are well behind those
states around us so yes I'm glad you
clarified that statute requires that
need be based upon New Hampshire solid
waste needs follow thank you followup uh
and right now what is the uh capacity
from other states that we're taking in
meeting their need currently do you know
currently and and it varies from year to
year I believe and Dees may be able to
clarify this we're in the range of about
45% we've gone back from year to year
between about 45 and 50% of what we
landfill coming from out of state thank
you okay okay thank you so much for
introducing this bill I know how much
you enjoy talking
trash
uh that's
true uh we we are we are coming uh up on
15 minutes to a heart break for lunch um
but I will invite uh Dees uh uh director
Michael whimet to come and speak on this
bill you ask for five
minutes and then what I will do is
recess this hearing until
2:30 uh no 1:30 we have another bill
scheduled so I will give that bill an
hour and then um we'll have have at 2:30
we would continue discussing uh or
hearing testimony on this bill okay
okay good morning uh uh Mike B record
Mike whims director of the waste
management division I'm happy to be here
to testify relative to House Bill 215
now the agency is not taking position on
this bill um we acknowledge that current
law doesn't provide a directive for Dees
to consider all potential harms or
benefits that might be associated with
citing an operation of a landfill uh the
department believes that some mechanism
for a broader consideration of these
potential impacts is worthy of
consideration um as representative
jamana indicated in his introduction to
the bill um the current law Provisions
direct Dees to make a determin of public
benefit when considering a landfill
permit application and those Provisions
set out the criteria for the Department
to use when making that determination
the aspects of public benefit relative
to determining whether a proposed
facility will address a waste disposal
capacity need has been the subject as
representative Jam indicated of Prior
appeals and and and that have gone to
the New Hampshire Supreme Court um the
court has provided the department with
some clear Guidance with respect to that
and uh we we
this bill would significantly alter the
criteria for public benefit relative to
capacity need determination and it could
potentially we think constrain
permitting in a way that um may not
allow adequate pass capacity to be
permitted and there and um we believe
the current law and the Court's guidance
um provide Dees with appropriate
latitude to make responsible public
benefit determinations with respect to
capacity that will achieve the broad
statutory goals um so stepping away from
that for a moment over the years Dees
has heard Express from both the
regulated Community the the folks
seeking permits and Community Advocates
and others um an interest in having um a
two-step process for considering
landfill applications one where in the
initial step or stage um the issue of
public benefit would be evaluated and
determination made um and also certainly
potentially in the context of this bill
an opportunity to look at broader
Community impacts both public both
benefits and harms that might be
associated with a proposed facility um
we uh there are some states that do that
and um we think that is worthy of some
consideration we know that um it can be
frustrating for all parties to be trying
to look at the whole landscape the whole
the sighting issues the public benefit
all the technical criteria all at once
when addressing opposed and pending
landfill application so um it it may be
that some kind of initial phase where
there's a consideration of the public
benefit as well as those other broader
considerations and then a decision made
so that if it's a no at that point
nobody has to work on it anymore and if
it's a yes at that point it goes to the
normal permitting processes across the
department and um we uh we believe that
could work in New Hampshire um I've had
some discussions with the sponsor about
possibly you know the need and the value
in studying that and trying to determine
what that would look like and how that
would work I would note that um the
department while we think we are very
well equipped to to implement the
current statutory regimen for permitting
uh we have the expertise and and the
resources to do a workmanlike job of
that um we don't believe that we're uh
really staffed or have the expertise to
look at some of these individually and
and unilaterally look at some of these
broader concerns such as um you know
economic impacts uh property values uh
Recreation Transportation issues you
know outside the in the in the region or
in the community and so that first stage
if there were to be one like that could
be one that was peopled with additional
experts um who would be able to weigh in
on those topics and give a reasonable
and fair evaluation of those broader
considerations so with that um that
that's the nature of where we're at on
this right now and I'm I'm happy to take
any questions any questions
representative H Haskins thank you madam
chair thank you director whimet so we
tried the two-step process last time
around and it's my recollection that the
department wasn't in favor of it so you
mentioned that you know a first step if
it didn't meet the criteria we wouldn't
need to go forward which was part of our
effort last time so I'm confused right
well um you know I think there were
aspects to that bill that we were not
comfortable with um and I'm talking
about a concept and an approach now that
I think is worthy of some study um you
know I can't say right now I know what
it should exactly look like or what
would work but I think studying it is is
is a worthy worthy Endeavor at this time
thank you representative Penza and then
representative grber thank you madam
chair following up on representative has
Haskins that actually was my bill and
um and hearing the positive factions of
this when Dees came out in in strong
opposition actually I had a employ a
conversation with an employee that was
all for it until um until they were
particular bill yeah I want to
understand how you can testify saying
that that's something that you guys
would consider when you came out
strongly against it it just seems like
we're talking out of both sides of our
miles I I don't hear a question there so
I'm not going to try to respond to that
yeah no I I don't think that that's an
appropriate
question
um if you can reframe it to uh you know
kind of something else pertaining to the
bill okay so try to explain to me how
now it's something that you're positive
against when you guys came out full
force against it before and now saying
it's something that you consider study
when that wasn't even on the radar at
all
through multiple hours of research and
testimony that I did my testimony this
morning is informed by a conversation
with the bill sponsor and and we stand I
stand by the testimony I'm providing
this morning representative
Gruber thank you uh CH uh Madam chair
um uh thanks for taking this question do
do you believe that the proposed
enhanced solid waste facility permitting
process that this bill oses um that
includes the net public benefit um
assessment has some elements or enhances
the process so it's close to the mission
of a Dees as well was and and second
part is the capacity of Dees to do this
in the
future as I've testified uh the the
agency believes that there it is
appropriate to look at broader
considerations than are currently
provided you we have clear Direction on
what we can consider and what we should
be considering to inform a permit
decision right now and it does not
include some of those broader
considerations we believe that those are
worthwhile to look at and as I've
testified this morning we believe there
may be a framework for doing
so okay any other
questions representative Scully thank
you madam chair so um if I understood
your testimony correctly you don't have
people on your staff who have the
expertise to look at some of these other
issues the economic impact issues or use
issues um would it in order for you to
be able to fulfill your mission to
evaluate would you be training your
existing people in some of these areas
or you do you need to bring in outside
subject matter areas uh
experts it's my sense that from the from
the language in this bill and from the
broader considerations that are being
discussed that that folks who have made
it their career and their and their
vocation to evaluate those things with
the things that are the folks who should
be evaluating it Dees is staffed with
engineers and geologists and
environmental scientists whose expertise
is evaluating um design and um potential
impacts on the environment groundwater
surface water soil that a particular
activity might um might impose they are
not trained and have not made their
careers in making those you know
evaluating Transportation impacts or or
noise or property value and I think that
there are other experts out there that
would could be involved in the process
that would provide that expertise in a
way that Dees isn't really equipped to
do representative kto had a question
thank you madam chair and thank you
director for taking my question I'm just
looking at a portion of the change here
um it says uh the impacts may include
and I'm going to skip over a lot um that
you are to include the emissions from
transport of solid waste related
material and byproducts to and from the
proposed
facility
now that to me is a pretty broad
statement and my question is is how
would anybody be able to do that study
because we don't know who because you
have you know your neighbors going to
the facility you have outside sources
driving how would you handle that how
would that be be able to be done because
there's you don't know who's coming and
going and you don't know what type of
vehicle they're driving Etc I mean is
there could you just elaborate on that a
little bit for me sure I think that you
know to the extent of study we're
required to look at those issues um
studies like that of that ilk are done a
lot they they use assumptions they use
as much information about the proposed
activity you know in terms of location
what type of waste it's likely to bring
in and where that waste is likely to
come from they can make reasonable
assumptions to report and and obviously
anything that's provided is going to be
a a a professional estimate but it's
going to be an estimate um and and and
so there are ways to do that what I'm
what I'm really pointing out is that and
that's an area where you know Dees has
done some work on climate change issues
on Transportation impacts on climate
change that may be an area where Dees
has actually got some expertise to look
at that um some of these other areas
like broader Transportation issues and
traffic and economic impacts that I
don't think were really um uh staffed up
and with the expertise to address those
issues okay thank you very much thank
you uh question representative wheeler
and then representative H Haskins thank
you madam
chair do you think that given those
concerns and the fact that Dees might
not be able to incur Transportation
traffic and economic concerns that other
departments in this you does this work
or yeah okay speak up all right they
cheaped out on the mics that's not my
fault
but do you think that director given the
fact that you don't have expertise in
your department according to your
testimony on Transportation traffic
economic concerns that a way to work
around that for this legislation would
be to put those under the perview of
departments in the state government that
would have to do with Transportation
traffic economic concerns others which
would have those expertise so you
wouldn't have to Sure worry about that
sure and and it's conceptual what I've
described but I think that you know a an
initial body looking at some of those
broader concerns could be peopled with
you know for example a person from the
Department of Transportation or a person
from the Bureau of uh of uh business
economic Affairs or something like that
or or or outside experts I mean I think
it would be up that and I think that's
the the nature of the conversation I had
with representative J was um you know
what would that group look like how
would it be staffed and and what and and
what criteria would they need to use to
make their decision this this bill lays
out the kinds of things that a study
will look at but it really doesn't say
anything about how to measure them
against one another uh and that's where
you know I think that's where it's
difficult for those things because
they're not something you can just put a
a number on and say it's either above
the number or below the number they're
they're a little bit more subjective
than that but that I think is what this
bill is asking is to take a look at
those broader concerns measure them
measure the the the perceived um impacts
that are negative against the perceived
impacts that are positive and make a
decision about whether in the language
of the bill a net public benefit um
results from citing a facility and
presumably that's how what a decision
hinges on and so this that's why I think
a study committee is necessary because
it's not it's not easy it's it's a very
difficult thing
um it's going to if it's not done well
it's going to um probably engender a lot
of appeals and a lot of uh controversy
um but if it's done well you can still
have appeals that's always going to be
part of the landscape but um at least
you've got some basis and you got the
right people in the room making a reason
decision using some guidance that's
provided by this
body okay um yeah sure followup let's
make it quick I know but uh
so your testimony is that you support a
study committee on figuring out this
issue amending this legislation to make
it a study committee would be your
testimony that's the nature of the
conversation I had with representative
jamman yes representative H Haskins
thank you madam chair and thank you
director whimet I don't want to lose the
forest for the trees this
conversation um has detailed to it in
terms of whether we could pull in other
departments that are already uh in house
like do to give us some um expertise and
the party the Independent party third
party agent that would write this report
would also be doing some of that um I
imagine that your department with
environmental science uh background and
um hydrogeology can read that report
effectively
um
again the purpose of the bill is to take
a look at the other side of the coin
that we haven't really examined that
these projects may have far-reaching
impact on our
communities and on our bodies of water
and I think that's the main point of the
bill um I would personally hate to see
it go off to a study committee because
I think the time is urgent and I'd like
to see us move forward with this Bill
thank
you I guess that was a statement it was
supposed to be a question supposed to be
a question
yes you do understand I feel certain
that the main point of the bill is to
study the harms this cost benefit
analysis has been going on in
departments federally for years so I
feel comfortable do you feel comfortable
that we could get that expertise to put
into this examination by the independent
third
party um I'm sure an independent third
party could be could be OB hired and and
contracted with to do the analysis as
was indicated by another questioner this
morning there's always going to be a
concern that any party hired by the
applicant is going to you they're going
to there will be folks who will question
the um whether that's their analysis is
unbiased or not so I think that where
the really the import of the decision is
going to hinge on who's sitting at the
table evaluating that information and
then making a decision about whether a
project moves forward or not and that's
where I think you need to have people
who are um experts in the areas that
you're evaluating quick followup if I
may no I we uh We've Come to noon and
unless you want to to uh continue
through and and and infringe on our time
to have lunch no I don't I just want I
would watching I would ask if uh
director whimet may be able to return uh
later today at 2:30 uh so that we can uh
continue to uh I ask questions I will I
will arrange my schedule so I can be
here at 2:30 okay thank you so then when
I'm going to uh call recess on this bill
until 2:30 this afternoon
and uh we will see you all at 1:00 so
that we can uh have our hearing for HB
240 thank
you
e
e e
still absent we're going to wait another
minute and then we can
proceed
e e
okay is there anyone else from the
committee outside
no you're
not one more okay we'll wait for one
more
okay so I'm going to call uh environment
agriculture committee to
order and I am going to open up the uh
hearing for HB 240 removing the penalty
of forfeiture for non payment of dog
licenses and today to present or
introduce this bill to this committee is
our representative Tom Manion welcome to
environment
agriculture thank you madam chair and
the committee uh so this is a real quick
I want to be clear what this bill
doesn't do is it doesn't remove licenses
doesn't remove
vaccine um proof it doesn't remove the
the court uh fine that may come with not
licensing your dog and then it also
doesn't uh remove anything to do with
the rabbit dogs or nuisance dogs that
would also get scooped up all I wanted
to do with this bill was to address a
concern from a constituent of mine who
um was in the middle of deliberations
with our our town clerk because their
dog could not receive a vaccine for
health issues every time it's very old
and every time it would go get the
rabies vaccine it would be like
paralyzed for a day had medical
conditions it was trying to work that
out so she's working that out between
the vet and the town and the automated
process where like she didn't file her
she didn't get it in in time uh sent
over a letter from the town clerk's
office to the board of Selectmen and one
of the Selectmen was she had a temper
tantrum when she saw that what the RSA
says is that they can send police to
your house to kidnap your dog over $25
late fee there's already a financial
penalty they can discharge it to dis
district court if you chose not to uh
pay pay your uh penalty to the town um
but it's like so it's like
46614 has this entire component where
they can ual warrant where uh men with
guns can break in come into your house
and take your family member away from
you and then you will if you were
already like having trouble paying for
that fee before to get your family
member back you now have to pay for the
um the you know it's maintained by the
facility veter and Veterinary fees that
the facility May benefit the dog and
these may be paid for by the town uh and
then you're on the hook for that before
they'll even give you your dog back so
that the objective of this goal was to
alleviate some of the fears of my local
constituent I man to get all the Reps
from pelum and our Senator on this bill
uh because this woman was terrified she
did not know that they that this existed
in the law so with that I'm happy to
take any questions thank you
representative
King thank you madam chair thank you
representative for coming today the
situation you were talking about is that
what would happen if they got the
vaccine but didn't pay the the the $25
fee yeah they also are supposed to send
a warning before that for you're
supposed to pay the fee from what I
understand understand if I'm
interpreting this RSA correctly they
send you a warning that you're supposed
to pay an additional $25 late fee and
then anything by I think it's like comes
uh June to 20 June 1st to June 20th it
gets uh the board of Selectmen wh
whomever will get a list of people that
didn't pay that $25 and then they're
going to come spend God knows how much
money in like police time to come seize
your dog and then house it and then pay
more money there to house the dog and
then if you never pay that fee the
town's on the hook for all that money if
you never pay it and it's over $25
followup followup uh thank you so um you
want to get rid of the ability of
officers to be able to come and steal
your family member what what um would be
a solution then because I could imagine
people gaming the system and just never
paying it I mean should there be a lean
on the person's house or what what would
ideally would be the solution then to
get them to so there's already a there's
a the section 13 uh mentions I can read
this here so the forfeiture it's a uh
you uh if it's not made for made to the
town clerk than 15 callor a days or
notice of forfeiture the case may be
disposed of to District Court as a
violation with an additional fine of $50
like this already exists in RSA so then
it's up to the courts um I don't know if
we need to add more here like this this
seems to me to be a pretty sufficient so
you're already on the hook here for like
$75 bare minimum for not paying your
original license fee I I just think
personally this seems egregious that
they're going to send armed men into
your house to kidnap your dog just
because you didn't pay $75 basically
thank you at at maximum represent
Freeman
could you put your mic on
please yeah I can hear you but go for it
thank you representative Manny for
bringing this bill forward whether
people think it's necessary or not I do
I was faced with a similar situation
with the dog that I had um first off
again um if this does not eliminate
rabies vaccines is that correct that's
correct yes that not none of that
statute is this is literally sections 14
15 16 that all have to do with like
issuing a warrant for the seizure of the
animal and how to return it do and it
doesn't eliminate the reporting of
rabies vaccinations correct none of that
is is removed can do you know
representative what happens to the
animals that are confiscated if the
owner does not have the means to pay for
that animal yes it's written in here um
after which time the title of the dog
shall pass to the facility unless the
owner of the dog has before the
expiration of the period caused the dog
to be licensed so then it's up to the uh
Town it'll be hand it over to the
facility so representative do you think
that means that that particular animal
is going to be in a shelter as opposed
to being in a home yes and and God knows
some shelters maybe kill
shelters I'm not even going to speak sex
I don't know any in the it's up to the
facility owner thank you representative
ktoa thank you madam chair and thank you
uh for being here and bringing this to
our
attention um a couple things um
now we know the importance of rabies
vaccines and we under I understand um
that this particular animal uh had
basically an allergic reaction uh to the
um the rabish vaccine did she try and
get an exemption from the state
veterinarian yeah that was uh she was
actually going through that I have like
the whole email chain here um it was
just and there was some kind of like
timing issue where like while she was
negotiating that something automated in
the town system kicked it over to the
Board of Selectmen with her name on it
and that they're friends like the board
of Selectmen is friends with this
individual so the board of Selectmen
lost her mind saying that you know
seeing holy crap they're going to go
like sees this person's dog that's a
friend of mine um I I don't know what
the end up the you know the end result
of this is but it was like an elderly
dog it's like 14 years old doesn't even
leave the property so that I understand
that getting these exemptions is is a
process that they can walk through and
it's going to take time from what I
understand representative com followup
thank you madam chair and and thank you
for explaining that
so I'm I'm a little concerned about
eliminating everything in in these
rsas however I I I agree with you that
if you're already going through the
process of obtaining exemption through
the state veterinarian office um whether
there's a timing issue or not you're
already they're already working on
something my problem is is that we know
that rabies is a public health issue and
there is no cure BAS basically it's
death if you get bit by anything
rapid um so if you remove the payment
portions I just want to it is not
removing the payment portions that is
section 13 this is
14156 which are specifically about
seizing the dog with using law
enforcement section 13 does have the
financial penalties it is also the
section that uh discharges it to the
district court to collect those fines as
well I have not touched that well
whatever this was a back and forth that
I had with OS they thought that's what I
wanted all I wanted was the part the 14
15 and 16 that deal with the physical
seizure of the dog via warrant and then
how to return it follow one more
followup thank you madam chair so let me
rephrase my question
okay the fee licensing a dog is so that
we can have a record of those that have
had their shots and up to date on
rabies or that have an exemption through
the state
veterinarian if we remove any
penalties I don't know how would we
address the people that are not doing
what is best for the public by getting
their dogs with their their rabies shot
I don't care about any of the other
shots the rabies one is the only one I
care about um for Public Policy right
policy
so what is the um
Where Do We Stand uh so as I was saying
that it doesn't touch the rabies it
doesn't you know the right rabies
section I think that's like section one
uh and it doesn't affect licensing
rabies it doesn't affect the financial
penalty or discharging it to the courts
for them to you know get even more
penalty Out of You This only affects the
part where they come and take the dog it
doesn't it also doesn't remove the
section 31 which has to do with nuisance
animals and dog bites and the police at
that point can seize the animal I
haven't touched that whatsoever that is
also still intact this is strictly
seizure for failure to pay the
registration fee thank you very much
thank you represent Bixby and then
Howard so um I just pulled up the
sections here and uh it looks like uh
the way that 46614 is written there is
not at at this point uh an exception Pro
procedure that could have been follow
that could be followed in the situation
where basically you're saying that your
constituent was just it was a matter of
timing rather than lack of willingness
that's my understanding yeah so I am I
am really hesitant to get rid of the uh
the capacity for the town to seize a dog
for someone from someone who is being
absolutely
intransigent uh however I think that
there should be an exception procedure
so would you be uh would would you be
interested in there being an amendment
which would add an exception uh uh so
that um the town can work with uh give
some leniency to people uh if uh if
there are extenuating circumstances per
perhaps like an amendment uh the way I I
st it because like there was actually a
uh I spoke to two Town one was a board
of selectman from my town and one was an
actual town clerk that messaged me and
both were surprised that this was here
that this existed at all and then when
the board of Selectmen from my town
talked to The Other Board of Selectmen
they were both saying we never actually
enforced this we only ever send it as a
scare tactic uh and I think it was the
molten Boro town clerk that was emailing
back and forth of me that she Mis
misinterpreted the LSR but she said
they've never sent out actual warrants
to arrest dogs either so it seems to me
that this this seems like a giant scare
tactic component to the law where if if
we want we should make this much more
strict for the requirements for doing
something like this like as opposed to
just some deadline every year it should
perhaps be as you describe like repeated
negligence uh if that's what the
amendment should be like four years what
whatever it may be like running problems
where they just keep falling behind year
year over year perhaps but like the way
that it seems is like uh especially in
my town it sounds like it was just
unautomated process the date came they
emailed the board of Selectmen here's a
list of people to send threatening
letters to and then we're not going to
actually follow up on
it okay so uh follow so the um the way
it's currently phrased the initial
sentence says the town or city clerk
shall annually between June 1st and June
June 20th per the local governing body
list of those owners of dogs that have
failed to uh to license or not renewed
their license pursuant to
4661 uh and then uh and then there's the
um issuance of the
license of the warrant so um I I what
I'm what I'm thinking is that rather
than have it quite so automated there
have this as uh something that the town
may do uh if if necessary is that
something it would be it's a lot better
than the current law I mean I'm happy to
meet both ways I just know this scared
the crap out of this board of Selectmen
scared the crap out of the dog owner
scared the crap out of me as a dog owner
like being as forgetful sometimes like
you forget to pay things and like God
knows if I get like a me letter in the
mail saying they're coming to seize my
dog I'm going to band down the hatches
and get ready for an
assault okay representative Howard
thank you madam chair um maybe even more
to the point would be to um uh
strengthen number 13 where where it goes
you know goes to the court rather than
to the selectman so that so and then the
court has the de has the opportunity to
to say you know is this is an elderly
dog or this is a a repeat negligence or
something like that and and still allow
for those penalties to happen for people
who really have gone around the band as
far as ignoring the health risk yeah
again that's a better better than the
current law any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you representative Manion um like to
call Tina
Guilford representing the town of Dair
town clerk one to two
minutes yeah need to put the um U sorry
microphone on thank thank you um my name
is Tina Guilford I'm the town clerk in
Dairy um we license about close to 7,000
dogs every year um
46613 creates the Civil forfeiture and
the Civil penalty and and and that is
being kept but the actual issuance of
the Civil forfeiture is in 650
66414 now we and Derry do not take
possession of the dog um it says that
the warrant may also authorize a local
law enforcement officer to seize any
unlicensed dog so the warrant in Dar
does not authorize seizure of a dog we
aren't looking to seize dogs we don't
want to take possessions of dogs I will
tell you that most of the people who do
not license on time and there are other
statutes prior to this that start the $1
a month late fee on June 1st and all of
that most people who don't license their
dog on time is because they don't have a
valid rabies on
file I mean we've automated the system
in Derry we send out email reminders in
January February and
March the end of March we send out an
actual paper Bill to anybody who hasn't
still
licensed and come May 1st starts the
grace period we also hold a rabies
clinic in town um it's like $15 to get
your um dogs rabies uh we do everything
we can to try to get people to license
their dog and assist them um in that
process however there are always people
who just don't they forget they don't
make
appointments and they end up then
getting the fine and then they get they
call they're really
upset um and they always seem to think
that they had a reason for allowing the
rabies to lapse for this for that that
it helps to have a very standardized
process that all the towns are kind of
using the same process I definitely
think that you can take out the um you
know taking possession of the dog
because I don't know that anybody wants
to do
that but the warrant process is what
starts the court process um and having
gone to court for these kinds of things
they always want to know when was the
Civil forfeiture issued the issued by
certified mail when was it delivered
when was it signed for that's all in
this warrant process okay and I'll take
any questions thank you representative
Freeman thank you madam chairman thank
you for taking my question do you know
um through the town do you have to
register with the state to let the state
know that um do we have a Statewide
rabies vaccine registry no no we do not
at this time um I know we uh we get the
Raby certificates that we have them our
law enforcement and Animal Control has
access to our dogs um sometimes we get
rabes certificates for people that have
recently moved and they forgot to update
the address and we try to forward them
to the right town but there is no
Statewide registry that I know of thank
you okay representative ktoa thank you
madam chair and thank you for coming in
and telling us about the process um
whereas rabies is a public health issue
do you think if people understood and
and maybe people don't really understand
the importance of rabies you think there
should be an educational component when
you send out these forages to say what
the liability could be to that person if
that dog has rabies and bite someone I
mean because to me that would be the
scarier part than a $25 fine I agree
with you and we definitely put some uh
information on the flyer and we do have
some information on there I I you can
give people information but you can't
make them read it and you can't make
them understand it thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much I call Angela
Ferrari from dog owners of the Granite
State and two
minutes all right this is on okay um
good afternoon thank you madam chair
members of the committee my name is
Angela Ferrari I'm here on behalf of dog
owners of the Granite State uh for those
of you who are new to the committee I'll
do a brief introduction but we are a
nonprofit organization that was
established in
1991 to represent the interests of all
pet owners in New Hampshire um our
membership includes a vibrant and active
community of specialty breed clubs uh
kennel clubs dog and cat breeders
veterinarians Hunters mushers you name
it um we have a really great membership
I have been with the organization since
2019 our position on h240 is that we do
oppose the bill um I think there's been
a lot of great discussion about the
concerns around rabies and its effect on
Public Safety um we are mostly concerned
with taking that stick away that is
going to push those people to get their
rabies uh vaccinations done there's some
things I think we have maybe some
veterinarians in the room who will speak
to it but when you get a rabies vaccine
the first one um within a year you need
to obtain your second one and then
you're good for every 3 years the towns
are also monitoring the expiration dates
on the rabies vaccines to make sure that
you are sticking within that protocol
and if you go outside of that then you
have to work with your veterinarian to
kind of restart the process and that's
going to um show as the expiration date
on the rabies um that would be submitted
to your town so there's a little bit of
administrative support um that helps
people ensure that they're following the
proper protocol for those rabies
vaccinations um so the loss of control
over dog licensing and the implications
for public health is definitely a
concern for us um as mentioned there is
an exemption for those dogs who have
health reasons to not obtain the rabies
vaccine um I do feel and the the
membership feels that what we have in
statute now really does allow us to
enforce that people are receiving those
rabies vaccines for their dogs I do
agree with uh representative bixby's
point about maybe having some leniency
if there is um an active exemption being
sought through the state vet and if
there is some type of proof that could
be provided to the town clerk that would
prevent um the the actual seizure of the
animal and that fee from happening um
but I do think as we've heard from
others that that fee and that seizure is
kind of what's going to drive those
people who are trying to avoid getting
the vaccination for their dog um
additionally something that I think
that's important that is kind of a
byproduct of this process with dog
licensing and getting that rabies
vaccine well there are clinics that you
can get your vaccine at a lot of people
are going to be doing their annual well
checks with their animals ahead of
getting their dog license making sure
they're up to dat on their rabies um so
I think we get an extra benefit while
not included in the law that people are
actually taking their dogs to the vet um
and having them checked out this is when
the veterinarians or are going to be
considering other vaccinations that are
important for the dogs although not
mandated by the state um parvo and
distemper are some of those that we'll
see come up and we do see that those
diseases are making their way more
rapidly into New Hampshire um so
anything we can do that's kind of
assisting getting the general public to
get their animals into the veterinarian
I think is also an added bonus that the
current RSA is helping to provide
something else you know it was touched
on that um mostly it's people who just
don't want to get the vaccine you know
or you know $25 they might be avoiding
wanting to pay for it especially if they
have multiple dogs each dog needs to be
licensed and vaccinated um that's
something that I think dog owners need
to take responsibility for and do for
their dogs a lot of people will say my
dog's never going to get exposed to
rabies he stays in the yard he's fine
but you never know when that animal is
going to come to the property it could
even meet you on the street as you're
walking down the road the animals that
have the rabies they're very strange
acting they do things out of the
ordinary so I think we need to continue
to urge and enforce that people are
going to be getting those
vaccines um with that I would take any
questions thank you any questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you very
much Lisa
Boer representing yourself and uh two
minutes to speak thank you
good afternoon Madam chair and committee
members my name is Dr Lisa Boer I am a
New Hampshire licensed veterinarian with
over two decades of experience in
emergency and critical care and general
practice I am in strong opposition to
hb24 as currently written the
vaccination of dogs against rabies is
the Cornerstone of Public Health
protection and we do know several things
for certain rabies is a serious disease
and 100% fatal in both animals and
humans it is also that known that the
vaccine is virtually 100% effective in
prevention of this disease rabies is
zoonotic meaning it is transmitted
through the bite or scratch of an
infected animal it is deadly and there
is no cure in the United States
approximately 10 people die from rabies
annually in 2023 despite appropriate
immediate rabies prophylaxis treatment
after a bite we still had deaths from
treatment or from rabies in New
Hampshire 20 to 30 animals or more test
positive for rabies every year without
strict vaccination protocols and
enforcement of civil fines for
non-compliance we leave ourselves
vulnerable to a potential Public Health
crisis I personally have a dog who has
an exemption to rabies for vaccine he
has an autoimmune disorder cannot be
vaccinated I took it upon myself to go
get the exemption from the state vet I
can't write it myself I managed to get
my license on time it takes planning but
it is very easy to do if you have a true
problem with the vaccine
I see te several types of pet owners
those who believe in vaccination and
those who feel it poses a risk for their
pet despite scientific research to the
contrary the rabies vaccine is a killed
virus and is safe in almost every dog or
cat with some exceptions without laws
and Licensing a substantial number of
pet owners would not vaccinate their
pets thereby increasing the risks of
occurrence of this disease in both the
pet and human population I have this
discussion with clients weekly I see
pets and people almost that have been
bitten or scratched by cats and dogs
when a bite wound occurs from an
unvaccinated or unknown animal it places
an undue burden on the bite or scratch
victim they have to seek costly Medical
Care and potentially they need rabies
prophylaxis treatment which is upwards
of
$20,000 the treatment increases um this
the lack of vaccination increases risk
to Veterinary staff members and in some
cases causes us to have to euthanize and
decapitate an animal and send the head
in for testing because there is no
premortem testing
there are risks in addition to the pain
and suffering of the pet who through no
fault of its own was not vaccinated and
not protected this build as I read it
does not just remove the language
dealing with the forfeiture of the pet
and it removes civil forfeiture which
should mean fines for non-compliance
this bill effectively eliminates all
penalty for non-compliance penalties are
a necessary deterrent the laws are Not
Mere suggestions they're binding rules
for the Public's well-being when
penalties are in place they create an
incentive for people to follow the law
knowing that there are real consequences
removing them signals to society that
compliance is not truly necessary for
example driving Under the Influence
regulations are designed to protect
lives if we remove penalties would
people take it seriously would we expect
people to voluntarily follow those rules
knowing there are no consequences for
Dangerous Behavior the answer to me is
clear without penalties the motivation
to comply decreases and the public
safety is jeopardized the risk to Public
Health from rabies cannot be overstated
even if it's rare in some regions the
consequences of a single Cas is
catastrophic and the threat is always
present if we eliminate fines for
failure to vaccinate we risk undermining
A system that is successfully protected
both human and animal populations for
decades furthermore enforcing the Civil
forfeiture incentivizes responsible pet
ownership it ensures that the people
understand the importance of vaccination
for their pets health and the well-being
of that of them and their neighbors if
we remove the finds that signals
non-compliance is acceptable which would
lead to fewer dogs being vaccinated more
potential exposure and mely more human
cases of rabies and I'll be happy to
answer any questions thank you
representative ktoa thank you madam
chair one could you pass your testimony
uh up to the clerk perfect thank you uh
and you have an exemption through the
state veterinarian um one how difficult
was it get and when a dog is exempt what
are the requirements for it to go
outside okay good question um and those
are some very really important issues
the exemption itself requires you to go
and have a certification by a board
certified specialist in this state this
is different there are I'm licensed in
several States some require just a note
from your veterinarian but you I had to
take my dog to a specialist who then was
willing to sign the waiver based on
knowing my pet and knowing the condition
that they had I then submit that waiver
to my town Brentwood and I get my
license for my dog there are
requirements that if my dog leaves the
property he should be muzzled he must be
muzzled that is the prop that is what we
have to do so we are in in my case my
dog was a service dog and then he got
six he's no long a service dog so it's
difficult you know for me I have to
muzzle them when I go out but I do so
thank you represent
vixy so um would you be uh how would you
feel about uh making a minor Amendment
to the law that would give the town
discretion uh in terms of sending the um
sending the the Civil forture warning uh
and uh and and warrant uh so that if
there is someone who is in the process
of working with the town to uh get the
get the appropriate vaccination and
licensure then they don't automatically
get that
warning I I have no problem with having
discretion I think we need to rely on
our you know people that work in the
towns and to do what's in the best
interest of you know the people who live
there however um my question is would be
back to that is that how long do we let
that go on you know I mean it didn't
doesn't take that long to get an
exemption if a true one is needed the
problem that I see and what I've seen
most often is people apply for the
exemption and they're not granted the
exemption and they don't like it because
they think that their pet still
shouldn't have a vaccine and then they
just ignore it perpetually so it's very
difficult to get an in in the sense of
you can't just say my pets had a
reaction and I'm not going to vaccinate
it again it would mean as me as if I
have a pet that I vaccinate that has a
reaction to That vaccine I would there
are other Alternatives you can pre-treat
that that pet with you know an
antihistamine and other things it would
be a professional Judgment of how to
manage to get that pet vaccinated safely
but if you can't do it like in my dog's
case there is no way to vaccinate him
safely I think there should be the
exemption and it should be something
that you know the the veterinarian that
a treating veterinarian should be able
to forward records even to maybe a a
specialist and then the specialist can
review that and say they concur as
opposed to maybe even having to see The
Specialist representative Freeman and
then representative
ktoa thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question Dr Boya sure how
difficult was it for you to find a
specialist uh took a phone call there we
have plenty of board certified Internal
Medicine Specialists in the state of New
Hampshire and and this this there's
another question with this as well as
statement you're a vet so you would know
right off the top of your head who would
specialize in this you're that is
correct ma'am I would say however if I
had a patient if you if you came to me
as a general practice veterinarian and
you and you brought me your dog and said
I can't vaccinate my dog for abies
here's the reasons why if I felt that
was legitimate I would put you to that
specialist and say this is who you need
to go see here's the paperwork they need
to sign i' send all the records as to
why you shouldn't have the vaccine and
then send have that specialist sign it I
mean I would coordinate that for my my
owner thank you and and just just out of
curiosity um what is the average cost to
taking your dog to a vet a specialist to
get a letter of
exemption I would say probably on the
order of about
$200 representative Bixby representative
uh come her question was answered so uh
do you happen to know if there is a list
of board certified uh Specialists on the
department of agriculture's
website I don't believe that there is
Sir and I think that's an excellent idea
although it would have to be kept
updated um you it's not difficult to
locate one on you can type in board
certified Internal Medicine veterinarian
New Hampshire and you can there's a link
to a list I mean their their
organization has lists but I don't think
that's a bad idea okay thank you okay
sure um any other questions thank you so
much for coming and testifying thank you
uh Stacy o from the American Kennel Club
you have two minutes you've
requested thank you chair Aaron members
of the committee Stacy Ober uh
government relations in New England for
the American Kennel Club and uh just
wanted to register akc's opposition to
House Bill 240 I don't think we could
over uh overestimate the significance of
rabies as a fatal threat and uh the risk
even has resulted for instance um back
in 20121 the United States Center for
Disease Control banned importing dogs
from more than 100 countries that are
not uh like the United States rabies uh
you know canine rabies um exempt and so
they've even moved forward in trying to
implement some additional rules because
we did have dogs that were imported into
the United States with rabes as a result
of fraudulent Health certificates so I
just raised that as as one issue
completely respect that this individual
has gone through the process of looking
to get the exemption and as I look at um
46614 I think it could be helpful to
refer to the exemption section because
it's not clearly stated that there is a
process there but secondly I would
discourage the committee from
eliminating the forfeiture piece and
that's even as a follow on to Dr Boer
noting that some people may just refuse
um to get the rabies vaccine they may
not be a candidate for the exemption and
because this is such a serious public
health issue there is no cure for rabies
it may be in the best interest of the
community to have that dog seized or to
have a big a big stick so to say in
terms of uh forcing that an animal get
uh vaccinated for rabies thank you any
other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony this
afternoon I am going to close this
hearing for H is there anybody else who
wishes to speak on this seeing none uh
can I have the blue sheet for HB
240 from up there and I'm going to close
the hearing for HB
240 and I'll wait for the blue sheet and
then we will proceed with the next
hearing uh yeah hang
on uh there were three in online there
were three in support six in
opposition and um for the blue sheet we
had forign opposition and
one uh person in favor
there you
go
okay I am now going to open the we're
running a little tad late about 9
minutes I'm going to open up the hearing
for
hb21 prohibiting the removal of Claws
from
cats and here to introduce the
bill oh
yes please please do
yes we'll have
to send law send law enforcement out to
seize uh representative board is if you
need me to introduce it I will yeah by
the way um I had our committee
researcher uh prepare report um
regarding past legislation and research
about banning the declo of cats um
because this committee has heard this
bill four times or three times before
and I just thought the committee might
be interested in what happened to uh
pass legislation so half of you go one
way half of you go the other
way um I will give him one minute I
found him you found him okay here you go
representative
bordes good afternoon representative
bordes and you are here to uh introduce
your bill uh hb21 prohibiting the
removal of Claws from
cats
y Oh I thought it was on nope guess not
now it's on um it's very similar to
House Bill 231 that passed the house in
2023 what this is is an act prohibiting
the removal of Claws from cats um as
many of you already know removing Claws
from cats is equivalent to cutting your
finger off at the middle knuckle It's
actually an
amputation it's uh not a surgery it's an
actual amputation that could be painful
to the animal um a lot of individuals
will get their cats declawed because the
cat's scratching the
furniture um to me that's unacceptable
It's a cruel
inhumane procedure many veterinarians
agree um I know we discussed before
actually a lot of corporate
veterinarians would not even perform the
procedure um and I I don't think it's
Humane to just because you can't might
scratch their Furniture to have them
their claw removed from them and perform
an amputation we wouldn't do that to a
child if he drew on the wall with
crayons so why are we going to do that
to an animal uh it's just cruel and
inhumane uh there are some exceptions
for medical reasons if say the cat has
cancer and that claw needs to be
amputated in situations like that there
are exemptions to this but overall this
is just the basic prohibit of removal of
Claws from the
cat any questions representative ger
thank you madam chair thank you
representative good to see you uh so uh
I my first question is a technical
question about the bill uh the the bill
itself the language makes clear in
section two starting in line 10 uh that
the this is a civil
penalty uh the analysis on the first
page says the bill creates a criminal
penalty for declawing a cat could you
clarify this is not a criminal penalty
correct it is in fact penalty correct
yes thank you and may I have a followup
mam chair followup sure uh thank you uh
representative have you heard from vets
as I have that this is something that
they would like to see in place so that
when somebody comes and asks them to
perform this procedure they can simply
say no it is not legal in the state of
New Hampshire I 100% I've heard that
from numerous veterinarians including my
own um you know a lot of the a lot of
practices will not perform it um but
there are still veterinarian practices
that allow it and some veterinarians do
not want to perform the procedure thank
you representative ktoa thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question um I know that we've heard this
bill before but I will I am really want
to know the statis itics on how many de
cat decls are being performed in the
State per year so we we've discussed
this numerous times nobody has been able
to pull those actual numbers down you
can't get them from anywhere um I mean
there's been some research done I don't
I don't want to misspeak so I don't want
to come up with numbers but the
procedure is still being done in New
Hampshire follow representative H
Haskins thank you madam chair and and
thank you representative bordis one
animal rights activist to another um
would you be open to an amendment that
said if someone had a um condition
physically that a cat with claws whom
they love could inflict harm on them
because of their medical disability
would you be open to such an amendment I
would have to see the I I would be open
to it cons I would have to speak to some
veterinarians and doctors about that um
cuz I do know another side condition of
the C and dcla now instead of scratching
they bite and a bite is actually more
harmful to a human than a scratches
indeed thank
you any other questions from the
committee seeing none oh representative
Freeman oh yeah okay oh thank you madam
chair thank you representative borders
for coming in front of us um I do have a
question would you be open to an
amendment that would take out the Civil
Penal penalties pot and just make it
illegal to do
this I mean if there's no way to enforce
it I don't understand why that we would
even I mean if we make it illegal what
with no penalty what good would it be
what do I have a followup followup well
I just heard someone say that some vets
need an excuse to say no correct so this
would give them the excuse to say no
would that not be would that not be
accurate if there's no well I guess I
could give them the excuse to say no I
just don't know what enforcement
mechanism you would have for people
violating
it well we can we can discuss that
further I just wanted to know if you
would be open to a friendly Amendment
I'm open to anything but I just want to
make sure what we're doing is proper and
there is some sort of enforcement
mechanism representative Scully thank
you madam chair thank you for being here
to answer give testimony to answer
questions um when it says no person
shall remove the claws does that refer
to the owner does it refer to the vet
who is the agent performing the actions
for the owner is it both it would be
obviously the veterinarian that was
performing the procedure if somebody
decided to decl their cat at home I
definitely think they should be charged
as well well it's a civil penalty but I
mean
that yeah that'd be pretty gruesome may
ask followup follow up thank you um my
concern is um
what would happen if a person who
adopted a declaw cat and then took it
into a vet for service would they
potentially be liable if somebody
dropped a dime on them and said they've
got a declaw cat I I couldn't see that
being an issue I mean the the declin has
been taken place previously I don't know
if we could do an amendment to clarify
that but I mean I don't see any issue
you know if the GU was already
previously declo or say he came from
another state decored there should be
some sort of record as far as
veterinarians that performed it or where
it was done to show that it was done
prior to this law being
enacted okay you had a
question okay representative Bixby and
then representative Miner just a
clarifying question so uh the bill uh
the bill bans the de the act of
declawing cats not the possession of
declawed cats correct 100% thank you yes
representative Miner thank you thank you
you uh representative boards now I've
spoken with a couple of veterinarians uh
from our community and um they say that
this procedure isn't uh isn't um huge in
nature do you have any idea how many
people how many cats are being declawed
we've been trying to get numbers for
forever there is no actual statistic to
show that I
think there's I know it's still being
performed in this state veteran Arians
admit it's still being performed but
there's no actual numbers to show
followup followup thank you so one of
the veterinarians that I spoke with has
told me that she's she's been a
practicing vet for 40 years and she's
done performed this twice so I don't
think it's widespread do you I think
it's happening a lot more than people
know thank you
Penza so I have two questions my first
question is since this bill um has uh
been introduced I think this would be
the fourth time and but I was here last
term and I went through all the
testimony and and and by the way on the
record I think it's absolutely the most
barbaric procedure if it's happening um
like you said just like a human at the
knuckle so um if we don't have the data
and everyone that I've talked to says
it's not happening and most vets even
refuse to do it um in Rochester anywhere
where I represent um why not put a bill
in to actually find out what those in
that information is like in requiring
vets to to do that why not amend the
bill so we have the data and if it's not
a problem then it's unnecessary
legislation that's needed so we've tried
to obtain data that there is no data
source to get that information from um I
don't think they're keeping accurate
records of it I I don't know why there
is no data but it's it's very hard to
find there's been some if you check
phone kind of surveys done with some
veterinarians in the area where somebody
would call up and say hey I'm interested
in having my cath declo is this a
procedure you with do and the
veterinarian will say yes that data I
don't have but there was a breakdown of
that um but it's definitely still
occurring in the state follow up but
that's my point instead
of we you know doing the same thing over
and over and expecting different results
so after the second time that it failed
why wasn't a legislation put in to
require vets to to put this reporting
criteria in so at least we would have
the the data I mean if we don't have the
data then we're obviously we shouldn't
be passing legislation based upon what
ifs it's not really what ifs because it
is occurring we just don't have numbers
on how often it's
occurring representative Bixby Madam
chair would it be appropriate for me to
um read some of the information from the
committee researcher that you uh
requested in terms of what's known about
uh
frequency um sure absolutely okay
so um there's no Central data collection
uh and uh it is uh there's no
requirement for reporting uh in 2020 the
New Hampshire uh Veterinary uh Medical
Association conducted a survey with
clinics in their database inquiring if
they allow
Decline and the survey results show that
86 out of 146 responses offered services
including declaw removal tail docking
ear cropping Etc so that's uh 80 more
than half of the uh veterinary clinics
surveyed in 2020 did offer this as a
service um and according to a uh January
2025 article uh a New Hampshire
veterinarian pulled data on declining
from her own practice before she bought
it in 2018 and banned the operation
there she found that at least 16 decla
procedures had been uh done there uh the
year before the practice was sold so uh
that doesn't give a clear sense of
prevalence but it does suggest that
there is in that it is in in fact still
happening is there a question there uh
no I I asked you if I could read that
information from from the from the data
I I thought you were going to read
something and then ask a question okay
so uh I just thought that that would be
in terms of instead of just sort of
asking questions about why don't we have
any data at least get the data that we
have okay thank you um I I wanted just
to say you know I've got several pin
cards here if you are signed up to speak
and you have already heard somebody say
something that you're going to say
please wave off U speaking because time
is of the essence and I guess
representative King you had a question
thank you madam chair uh my apologies if
this has already been answered but um um
do you believe that your bill either
would or should hold somebody civil
liable if they take their cat out of
state to get the procedure
done that's a I think I think they
should be held silverly liable because
it it's would be against New Hampshire
state law I don't know how you would
enforce that to be honest with you or
what sort of enforcement mechanism you
would I mean how do you prove where the
cat was declo but I mean mean I know our
nebit in the South which I know we're
different then but they just passed the
same exact law in Massachusetts so they
it's starting to become more and more
common a lot of municipalities and are
enacting similar laws thank
you represent
Penza so I was educated over lunch which
um I have a I I love cats I had cats
can't have cats now my husband's
allergic so I was educated over lunch of
the new version of cat uh declaw that
has been in place in practice for a long
time versus the one that I'm familiar
with from 40 years ago which is the
horrific practice so what if the numbers
that he just gave are where it is not
touching at the knuckle they're actually
it's just doing at the claw and there's
like this special glue if that is the
case and what they're using now with all
of the technology that we have which we
didn't have 40 years ago then you bill
becomes null and void because it's not
doing that type of what we're talking
about which is really abuse it's I mean
it's still being done that way as far as
I know um I mean the ma majority of
veterinarians will have said that's the
way it's been done um I mean they make
claw protectors now that you can put
over your cat's claws if you're worried
about the cat scratching Furniture but
to me
amputating at the digits is just
humanely
insane representative
wheeler would you believe that the clat
decl the clat decline the cat decline p
uh procedure that representative patens
described still does when you put the
glue in create a problem for the cat and
its ability to walk after the
procedure's been done for many months
afterwards because the cat's claws are
similar to how our little toe if we lost
a little toe we might be off balance a
little bit the cat Clause is a big part
to it to its balance so even taking the
cloud and the and the way they do the
procedure now is is still damaging to
the cats actually yes you are correct in
that statement also when it comes time
to go use the litter box and such
sometimes they stop using their lit box
they off balance they don't have as much
control the other aspect which I didn't
bring up is you have an indoor cat you
get it declo he escapes gets outside
there's no defense mechanism for that
animal they can't climb up a tree they
can't protect themselves they're
basically just sitting there as prey at
that
point represent
Bixby so um a new This Modern procedure
has been mentioned and I'm wondering if
that's one of the ones that is listed in
the bill so the bill lists uh onomy
partial or complete fing
fomy tend tendonectomy uh is that is
that procedure that representative Penza
and Wheeler mentioned one of those or I
would have to check back to actually
look at the medical terms um I'm not
positive to be honest with you thank you
any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much
bis I'd like to call uh Dr Lisa Bo Boer
hi again you need to put your microphone
on thank you is that on now sorry than
all right hi so I'm still Dr Lisa Boer
and I'm still a New Hampshire
veterinarian with 23 years of experience
but I'm also a court- qualified expert
in multiple jurisdictions in Animal
Welfare cruelty and abuse and I strongly
oppose this bill for several reasons it
number one um it removes my autonomy as
a veterinarian to make a medical
decision about a patient it also removes
an opportunity for me to educate clients
if an owner comes to me and asks about
declawing their cat we engage in a
lengthy discussion including what
prompted them to want the procedure and
more importantly we'll explore the
problem and alternative Solutions I
personally do not perform declaw and
frankly I don't need the legislature to
tell me I need an excuse to say no if I
choose not to do that I'm capable of
telling my client no I don't do
convenience euthanasia either there you
that this would have no impact for for
me I'll say no regardless of the law the
um sometimes those these discussions
will lead to a medical diagnosis and
treatment of a problem where the owner
thought the declaw was the solution but
it really was something else and that's
important to me the legislation
diminishes the collaboration between a
loving pet owner and a trusted
veterinarian the public understands that
veterinarians do not wish to do harm to
their patients we take an oath to
protect the health and welfare this law
undermines my professional judgment and
is an unnecessary law that frankly will
have no effect on the Health and Welfare
of cats in the state of New Hampshire
another issue is if legislators should
substitute their judgment about medical
procedures where you they do not have
the scientific knowledge to make that
decision this would be the first time
that New Hampshire lawmakers would
publicly be questioning a profession's
Integrity by agreeing with Bill
proponents that New Hampshire licensed
veterinarians are engaging in animal
cruelty activity that needs the state to
intervene and stop this is not true and
it's an unacceptable slippery slope our
knowledge science and medicine evolve
over time procedures we did 20 years ago
have improved and if we ban a procedure
now and our knowledge changes later are
we going to go back and Rel legislate
this I don't think so how is this bill
going to be enforced is there going to
be an inspection of hospitals records
who's going to enforce it and frankly is
a civil fine really going to change
anything some people feel decline cats
is animal cruelty and in reality when
performed by a veterinarian with proper
technique anesthesia post-operative care
including pain management it isn't
animal cruelty however we still can
choose not to do it in 2020 the avma
revised their decline policy and
discourages the decline of domestic cats
as an elective procedure the association
however encourages the use of
Alternatives but says professional
judgment is key when making a decision
as to whether a dclock hat why do
lawmakers feel they have more
professional judgment than a highly
trained and properly licensed Medical
Professional my final point will address
um representative Bixby that is this
really a problem at all in the state of
New Hampshire when you read that
statistic from the study of the nhvma
that 86 out of 100 offered those
Services I bet if you took that
statement and only asked about declaw
you would find almost none I cannot
recall the last time I have seen a
declawed cat in practice even not even
that coming to me for a declaw just a
declawed cat period it is I don't we
every colleague I know does not do these
procedures this is a law in search of a
problem and I urge you not to infringe
upon my rights as a veterinarian to make
an ethical informed and appropriate
medical decision for my patients and
clients and I'm happy to entertain
questions thank you and can we have copy
of your testy to representative German
thank you madam chair and thank you Dr
Boer for taking my my question so the
the bill uh States clearly clearly on
line five lines five and six that uh
there are exemptions for a physical uh
and medical condition of the cat in
other words for uh conditions that a
veterinarian would deem for for the
health of the cat so could you explain
to me looking at the language of the
bill how this takes away the ability of
a veterinarian to make that
determination and what in the language
of the bill interferes with a
veterinarian to talk to
someone who comes into their practice to
ask for the procedure you're you're
preventing the person from coming
through the door in the first place if
they call and say do you declo cats we
say no they go somewhere else we can't
even start the discussion they won't
ever get to their veterinarian to have
that discussion and so and you know and
this is for me um much like um any other
procedure I'm you know we have every
veterinarian has their moral and ethical
line but we're all really sworn to help
promote the health welfare of animals we
all have continuing education
requirements we all are well aware of
Pros cons you know of any kind of
medical procedure that we do and I I
really would challenge those numbers
from the nhvma I I don't think that it
is even really being done I don't know
anybody who in the state that does this
procedure and if they do the procedure
certainly not by clipping off the ends
of you know the the joints I mean
there's there's other ways to do it I I
don't feel that that bill necess it see
how I put this the bill may not tell me
I can't make a medical decision for my
patient but my what the bill is doing is
saying that we need the legislature to
dictate how we practice medicine and
that's the problem we get into because
this will be the first of many other
things that could come down that road
now the next thing if we ban this what
else are we going to ban are we going to
go through every list of procedures that
a veterinarian can perform and now
decide which ones we can and can't do I
think that's wrong I really do I think
it's wrong for people and I think it's
wrong for Animals I have followup Madam
chair followup yeah thank you very much
I appreciate that uh can you give us
some guidance and some advice on how to
think about this when we have a
veterinarian testifying as you have and
we could have an equal number of
veterinarians on the other side of the
issue so we have somebody making a very
compelling argument you have but we also
have like my personal Veterinary and
making a very compelling argument on the
other side so U how do you think we
should approach this issue when we have
very uh expert uh Witnesses giving us uh
uh advice that's in kind of 180 degree
opposite directions I think that's a
great question I think first of all I
will not sit here and tell you that
doing decline cats is okay all right I'm
not going to tell you that that's true
cuz I don't I personally don't do the
procedure because I don't like to do the
procedure I'm not I and I don't just
there's no reason for it I have other
Alternatives at my disposal other than
decline cats however there may be that
one time that I have a patient where
maybe that is the only alternative to
prevent a euthanasia or and if it can be
done in a Humane or safe manner I'd like
to be able to have an option anyway and
it's I mean in my entire career I have
done exactly one declaw they don't even
train it in Veterinary school anymore I
mean it's not something you're taught so
it's something You' have to learn how to
do and I just I think the it goes beyond
just decline I if why do we need a bill
for something that really isn't occur in
my experience occurring the state any
veterinarian should be able to tell
their client no I'm sorry I'm not going
to do that we have that right we don't
we're not at the you know at the behest
of our client to do medical procedures
we aren't okay with just as I wouldn't
do a surgery I wasn't comfortable with I
wouldn't do vaccine I wasn't comfortable
I wouldn't do a medical treatment I
wasn't comfortable with that's that's on
me as a professional I don't think the
legislature needs to mandate that thank
you very much represent
Penza thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um very
compelling
testimony do you have any idea when like
the date of um when they stopped
teaching
it well I a 2002 graduate it wasn't I we
although they weren't teaching it in
school it was still performed I don't
believe I I know that we don't te it
hasn't been taught as a regular
procedure they're too busy just teaching
basic spays and neuters you know I mean
they really don't teach a lot of those
other kinds of procedures in school but
if we do get education as to what the
procedures are maybe not how to
physically perform them what the nature
of those procedures are there is
education about the pros and the cons of
those procedures you know what actually
happens when the procedures are done
what are the consequences of that
procedure so I think veterinarians are
well educated as to the positive or
negative outcomes of that type of
procedure and I think it still relies on
their professional judgment in in a
total but I I I think I would ask the
committee if you really want the numbers
to know who is performing those these
procedures if I mean that's what you
need to get down to right so why not
have a
study that says and I don't think has to
be legislated study but why not have
some research where the veterinarians in
the state of New Hampshire are surveyed
and just leave it as decline
only okay don't lump it in with tail
ducks ear crops and everything else
because if you called a clinic and said
do you do these four procedures well
maybe you don't do one of them but
there's no way 86 out of 100 clinics do
declaw I guarantee that thank you very
much thank you any other questions
represent Barber yes thank you Dr Bo for
your testimony
I have a a question about informed
consent have you had patients uh I'm
sorry cat owners come in to ask you
about the declawing had the opportunity
to discuss the procedure the
outcome um the
details and if that's the case how many
of them then go forward go continue to
ask you can we then go forward with this
that's a phenomenal question actually I
think when properly educated owners
would virtually never elect this
procedure okay can I ask another
question sure
followup thank you yes my other question
is about um uh the recording of
information
statistics are you required to um tell
the state when you provide a rabies
vaccine or any other vaccine or other
health issues having to deal with the
animals in your practice do you have to
report anything to the state
no and and frankly I I think that that
opens up a whole can of worms you know
if we have to report every single
disease or every single procedure we do
that gets very difficult and it may even
infringe upon owner confidentiality I we
don't have Hippa but we have
confidentiality one last question yes
related to that
um if we were to ask ask in the search
of the numbers that we're talking about
is that something that you think
veterinarian practices would be willing
to do on an anonymous basis to give the
reporting of how many of these
procedures they
do I think if it were a properly framed
survey that was truly Anonymous yeah I
do think most people would answer that I
do I don't see why they
wouldn't any other questions from the
committee
thank you Dr Boyer um really appreciate
your testimony today thank you and you
do have a copy for the clerk
okay next I'll call Kurt aronburg from
the Humane
Society I'm
sorry thank you
uh good afternoon thank
you my name's Kurt aronburg I'm the New
Hampshire director for the Humane
Society of the United
States and I'm here to talk about cat
decline first a raise your hand if you
love
animals that's everybody anybody not
raise their
hand okay it's kind of funny but but I
like veterinarians too I hear all the
time from all of you how much you love
animals I'm walking around here oh I
love animals I have two cats I how many
cats do you have who has a declawed
cat
anyone yeah so we all love animals this
bill is cruel and this bill is about
ending cruelty to
cats and when we hear from veterinarians
all they can tell us is don't tell us
what to do we don't do I don't you can't
find a veterinarian in this state who
will tell you that they do it but you
call them up and they'll offer the
service and uh that statistic is
undeniable it's the only one we have
actually right now is
86% offer
it 16 cats we know from that paper from
this committee
were declawed how many years ago four
three
two yeah so recently recently enough so
that question let's put that to bed it
happens it's cruel it's
unusual
period so I just go through a few things
about the
procedure there's no valid reason for it
by the
way in the the bill there is an
exemption for veterinarians to do the
procedure if they think it's
necessary
period okay you can you can easily trim
the nails of a cat to keep it from
scratching you or to keep it from
damaging your
furniture the CDC the Center for Disease
Control says it's not
advised to to decla hats for Hume any
kind of human health
issue the national hemophilia
association does not recommend
Decline and scratching for cats is
natural and
necessary remember what we're talking
about not withstanding any fiction about
new procedures what's in the bill is the
cutting off what's in the bill is the
cutting off of the tips of the cat's
fingers toes whatever you want to call
them that part of the Paw irreparable it
changes the way they live they can no
longer defend themselves with their paws
or their claws so they bite
people or whatever that threat may
be I'm trying to be
brief so much
misinformation to
correct okay the tip of the Paw bass
basically has glands that are necessary
for the cat to exist scent glands things
like
that I want to reiterate veterinarians
retain the ability to do whatever they
need for the health of their patient
it's they can't do it for cosmetic
reasons or the convenience of an owner
who doesn't want to get
scratched um it's being come becoming
more widespread in Europe it's almost
the entire European Union has banned it
um and I'll just once again the
objection that it's not being done in
the state we've dealt with that 86% of
vets offer it it's it was done 16 times
in 1917 or whatever 2017 I'm getting old
um for medical autonomy the veterinarian
has Medical autonomy to do the procedure
if they think it's medically
necessary and if we have 86% who offer
it but we can't find a
vet to admit that they do it they must
be ashamed of doing it and even the
person who who spoke before me oh I
would never do
it I would never do it but I need to be
able
to and the uh the question of human
Health we've dealt with um I I sent I
think I sent everyone a fact sheet and
some letters from some people uh not all
of you but most of you
um and that that that would be my
testimony again I would just say to to
to surise if you've ever had a cat loved
a cat known someone who's loved a cat
love someone who loves a cat you got to
vote Yes on this bill
questions from the
committee representative Barber thank
you so much for your testimony you
mentioned that 80% 86% of veterinarians
in New Hampshire offer
decline I'll uh def defer to
representative big it was the survey
said 86 out of 146 so that's not
86% it's lower sorry I got that wrong
I'm really bad at math
I'm sorry
followup follow up on that if we're
using that number um is that anecdotal
is that selfreported is that simply by
phone calls or is that an actual um
number that was gotten by written survey
ET is that a question to
me if you so in this I'll hand out that
we got from Judy from representative
Aaron uh the numbers are in there
okay that a question was that a question
because I'd like to address it no she
just wanted some clarification and and
i' Madam chair I'd like to clarify a
little bit further the the uh numbers
for representative Barbara that those
statistics didn't wasn't just about it
asked about several procedures not just
declaw so if they performed any one of
those procedures mentioned they're
included they may not even include a
veterinarian clinic may not even do a
declaw but they would be included in
that
number one is too many one
kitten who has subjected to this
procedure unnecessarily in this state
because you refuse to address this is
one too many repres um Mr arenburg that
that's out of line
I don't appreciate apologize I
apologize any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony this afternoon I
call Jane Barlo Roy
I apologize for my delay I just put a
cough drop in so I no
worries thank you for very much for
letting me testify today my name is Dr
Jane baroy I am representing the New
Hampshire Veterinary Medical Association
um but I also represent the um delegates
of New Hampshire um at the American
Veterinary Medical Association and I
apologize if I lose my voice um I have a
head
cold the New Hampshire Veterinary
Medical Association in conjunction with
the American Veterinary Medical
Association strongly opposes hb21 we
believe the adoption of hb21 would
undermine the professional Judgment of
New Hampshire veterinarians and disrupt
the essential Veterinary patient client
relationship this relationship is the
Cornerstone of the Veterinary Medical
practice and ensures collaborative
decision- making between clients and
veterinarians to achieve the best
possible outcomes for their
pets it is critical that veterinarians
retain this authority to exercise
professional judgment when making
clinical recommendations in the best
interest of their patients our
association respects and supports the
clinical expertise of our members
empowering them to work closely with
clients to determine the most
appropriate course of care like most
surgical procedures complications May
occasionally arise for various reasons
however most of these complications can
be effectively address through
established medical
interventions we recently pulled our
members as to whether they offer declare
declaw routinely and the vast majority
replied that they do
not 83% do not offer it at all the
remaining only offer it as a last
resort this fact shows overwhelmingly
that our membership is not pro declaw
and tying this data from previous
surveys we have done the majority of our
membership resents government oversight
into the procedures in our
profession enacting this bill would
simply be virtue signaling allow my
members to retain their autonomy in
decisions that affle their clients and
patients and with all due respect the
survey that we did back in 2020 was a
combined survey for the two bills that
were brought up in front of the
legislature so to put that data together
um is not an appropriate use of that
data in my
opinion um I will take any questions
that you have for me today thank you
representative German thank you madam
chair uh and thank you for taking my
question and it's it's a simple one and
that is in your judgment is it hum
inhumane to remove a cat's clause for
purely cosmetic reasons or purely for
the convenience of the
owner I think we're confusing the
definition of
inhumane in regards to medical
procedures by veterinarians if you use
that type of definition the majority of
medical procedures we do on animals
could be considered
inhumane simply a cat neuter could be
considered inhumane because most of us
that have come in contact with a male
intact Tom Cat Knows
that these cats stink to high heaven you
cannot have a male intact C cat in your
house and not neuter them and so purely
neutering a cat for those
reasons is Cosmetic in my
opinion so no it's not inhumane
necessarily to new to declot a cat under
proper anesia and anesthesia to declaw a
cat in your kitchen yes and I agree with
Dr Boer when she made that point as well
today follow up follow up thank you with
regard to to neutering aren't there
numerous uh health reasons and other
kind of beneficial byproducts of of
neutering for example preventing Mass
reproduction of animals that then may
not be careed for like neutering is not
considered by representative I'd have to
G you because that neutering really
doesn't have bearing on this particular
bill
oh I'm confused because she was using
neutering as an example of she was
talking what what might be considered
inhume treatment if I may she she said
that neutering could be considered
cosmetic and I was asking her how that's
the case
sorry you had I'm sorry go ahead I I
will address that
um
when can you repeat your question please
go right Ahad just that there are uh are
there not a lot of other health benefits
and positive benefits to neutering that
make it not really considered cosmetic
by most veterinarians so when you
suggest the health
benefits the health benefits of a lot of
things are naturally occurring things
that animals do animals reproduce and so
to use that as an argument that we're
controlling the pep
population reproduction is a
normal
biological event Behavior just as
scratching is a natural behavior for
cats so to me that's not necessarily a
health benefit to the cat it is a
benefit again to the owner because
you're not having unwanted litters thank
you representative ktoa thank you madam
chair and I am going to go off track and
continue on with the line of discussion
that we just had um
it could be said that the neutering or
the spaying of an animal can actually
decrease its lifespan is that
correct I'm not positive about that
information um there's a lot of research
being done into delaying spaying and
neutering for health benefits um there's
a lot of research that is being done on
looking at retrospective studies um
unfortunately there has not been really
good data out there because most of
these research papers are being done
um retrospectively meaning they look
back at say a 100 animals and they look
back at their records to say when they
were spayed when they were neutered um
other procedures that they may encounter
in their lives are not included and so I
think there's a lot of information that
is being put out
there because we're viewing the data um
to to reach a means to an ends that we
might want to get thank you very much
representative
Penza thank you madam chair um and thank
you for taking my question do you
represent um every single uh
veterinarian in the state like are they
all members of your
Association I represent the
members that I represent the New
Hampshire veterinarians that are members
to my
Association um could you I don't
represent member people that are not
members um as of December 31st um that
was the end of our our fiscal year um we
had over 350 some odd members um you
know that are members of of the New
Hampshire Veterinary Medical Association
follow up follow up do you know how many
there are in the state out of if you
have 350 are there a thousand vetenarian
so from from this the the board of
veterinary medicine there are over 900
member
board licensed in the state of New
Hampshire however because we are a
border state um we have many um
veterinarians that are are are licensed
in other states that don't necessarily
practice in New Hampshire um there is
really no way unless we go practice to
practice to find out how many licens
veterinarians that are practicing in New
Hampshire are um it's just it's it's
very difficult because also our
membership in the New Hampshire VMA um
we give discounted memberships um to
students we also um allow membership
from veterinarians from out of state um
in order to access our continuing
education any other questions uh
representative H Haskins thank you madam
chair I'm just trying to get the numbers
right in my own head do you support the
survey in 2020 when asked the specific
question of the New Hampshire veterinary
medicine Association Medical Association
would you approve of New Hampshire
making the practice of decla
illegal half of them said yes half of
them said
no I did that survey myself um I was the
one that put that survey together and
actually the numbers um I believe are 51
to 47 um or somewhere in that that area
um and the majority were not in favor of
legislating this and so I have to go
with my membership um I understand that
50% of us or half and half are are are
split on this um but again I have to go
with my my membership's majority thank
you representative Penza sorry last
question thank you madam chair um I've
talked to a lot of constituents about
this bill um and it seems as if a lot of
people are on board with that would you
be amendable do you think the
association would be amendable to
the state actually Gathering the data
like how often it's happening or even
just a specific question that's asked
out to every board certified licensed
veterinarian in the state to say are you
performing these are you not how are you
whatever like would you I would gladly
take help um I have been in front of
this
committee I more times than I can count
I've lost count um and the information I
try to gather every single year I can
only get the information that I email
out to my membership and I can only
process the data that I get from the
responses I have never been able to get
good data from my members I've not been
able to get that data at all so I would
very much gladly appreciate any help in
getting that information for you I have
done my darnest to get you accurate
information the results that I got from
this last survey were from last week and
again I can only get data I can't keep
sending out survey after survey because
the people that respond to
surveys are the people that respond to
surveys so if I send one out next week
it's going to probably be the same group
of people and I'm not going to get a
representative sample so if there was
any way that we could get that
information beforehand before any of
this legislation comes up and I would be
more than happy the association would be
more than happy to go through any of
these resol excuse me I just came back
from our own any of these these
legislative
information before any of this even
comes in front of your committee so that
we can actually present a bill that
everybody has the information and I ask
every single year for the sponsors to
come meet with us as an association meet
with the Board of veter Medicine before
this even gets to in front of you so
that we're not wasting time going
through data that is way out a date 5
years in the veter medicine medical
profession changes a lot things change
rapidly and that information that I got
five years ago is wildly wildly
wildly
inaccurate just as medical procedures
happen change in five
years so I'll be glad to take the help
I'll be glad to help create a bill if
that's what this body wants but nobody
has ever come to our association
never
questions thank you appreciate it and I
do have written I have testimony from
the American Veterinary Medical
Association please pass it
along I have
Robert C
kale I'm sorry I don't I can't read
it from rochest sister could that be
cook yes that would be me and if if
you've heard something before that you
want to say please don't say it
again I have been accused of that before
in my life but try
to not do that uh my name is Robert cook
I live in c k okay I'm a resident of
Rochester I'm a licensed Forester for
the state in the state of New Hampshire
um and just a couple of words I like to
say
um talking comparing the um neutering
with declawing neutering is a surgical
procedure that is done on anesthesia and
typically there are no lasting effects
from that the lasting effects from
declawing I have seen firsthand I
volunteer in at least two animal
shelters I'm also a member of the New
Hampshire disaster animal response team
if you want and the second thing about
what was said before me you know try to
get the numbers try to get the numbers
try to get the numbers the definition of
insanity is trying to do the same thing
over and over and getting the same
result if you want numbers pull the
shelters in the state veterinaries
perform the procedures and get paid for
it shelters deal with the outcome and
the outfall from
it there's more animals that are
surrendered to shelters because they h
cats because they have been declawed
rather than because they're scratching a
sofa it's it is a in the veterinary
textbooks it says is an
amputation so it's literally amputating
all 10 fingers if
not
more how is that and there are
circumstances where that's medically
necessary it's a very small percentage
and yet the large percentage of the
procedures that have been done have not
been because it's medically necessary
this bill has the out for medically
necessary that still gives the
veterinarians the legal and um medical
reasons for performing this procedure if
it needs to be
done but go to a shelter see a cat who's
been walking on their wrists for years
because they cannot walk so many cats
get surrendered to shelter is because
they go to the bathroom outside the
litter box why do they do that because
they can't do what's natural in the in
the um
litter behavioral problems
they're if you if you want numbers and
this is so
this your numbers are is it being done
in the state is it not being done in the
state go to a shelter you see cats get
surrendered it's being done in this
state do you need to know how many you
know that this cruel and unusual
punishment is being done and you have
the ability to stop it thank you and
thank you for being our Representatives
this is civic duty at its best thank you
appreciate it
questions seeing none thank Youk
you uh Lisa smart The Honorable Lisa
smart oh had to leave okay all right so
we will
that over there
um we have uh Christina
Snider hello thank you for having me
today
um I just want to say real quickly that
a few days ago when I knew this bill was
coming up I it only took me 5 minutes to
find two veterinarians that do this
procedure and that was a simple Google
search and then one of them actually
even had a Google review where someone
wrote up that they had the procedure
done so clearly this is being done how
much I don't know but like uh someone
before me said one is too many it's
happening absolutely it's happening and
this is uh this is animal cruelty as far
as I'm concerned it's animal mutilation
if you were to go out into the wild and
you were to chop off the fingers of a
raccoon or a bobcat that would fit under
the animal cruelty statute and that
could be up to a felony charge so here
we are doing it with house cats you know
there's those loopholes those famous
loopholes where it's it's animal cruelty
here but it's not animal cruelty here
and um I did have a cat that was
declawed and I adopted him when he was
two and I watched him suffer his whole
life and I will say this I think there
was someone speaking before me that says
this might reduce their lifespan my cat
lived to 24 years old and especially the
last few years of his life he suffered
badly because he had Pro problems
walking on his
paws and towards the last week or two of
his life he lost the
fur the fur was gone from his paws and
you could see the knuckles boom there
was nothing there and it was awful
because I had to make the decision do I
put him down do I keep him alive and it
it was this is horrific thing to do and
I always you know I mentioned this last
time I said if I had when I got that cat
and I saw how much he was suffering
without those
claws that if I had one choice between
someone giving me a million dollars or
giving my cat his claws back hands down
I would give my cat his claws
back this is just it it's it's
unbearable to me that we are here
constantly
doing this same bill wasting taxpayer
money sitting here for 3 hours going
over the same testimony there is a very
easy solution for that pass something
please please because I already I'm got
to tell you right now I have two State
reps ready to do this again that's two
more two more years that this is going
to happen something has to be done
please please do this and I will say
that I I kind of I'm kind of curious
ious about why you know the we don't
deal with facts we deal with what if
slippery slope we deal with these things
the facts are this is being done the
facts are this is mutilation of an
animal and the fact is that these
animals
suffer please do something please stop
this from happening I am begging you if
if you had seen I I wish I had taken
pictures of his paw I mean that cat was
my baby he was my baby so it's very hard
for me to listen to some of this you
know a slippery slope nobody knows
what's going to happen 5 seconds from
now the roof could cave in Nobody Knows
the future if you legislate on slippery
slope what what does that do no bills
would ever be heard because anyone could
make that argument we are here dealing
with this today we are talking about
cats not dogs dogs is a separate species
this is a cat
Bill I'm just going to leave with
again this bill will keep coming around
on that lazy sus in the circle I'll make
sure of it and I owe that to my cat
thank you very much
questions representative
Penza thank you thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question I'm
sorry um when um when did you adopt the
cat like when was that I I adopted the
cat
in uh Texas and then he died in
2019 so um you know he was in it was in
the '90s that I adopted him and you know
maybe the procedure has gotten better
but you know I got to tell you it sounds
a little wonky to me to say oh now it's
it's it's better because they only do
this they only do this if it's anything
more than Nail clipping something is
being done something serious is being
done to that cat you know and as far as
well spay and neuter
humans we get you know males get
vasectomies I mean it's it's a it's a
bizarre thing to use that as some kind
of a an argument to say why we should
you know keep this procedure in place
and as far as you know there's a
veterinarian and the owner and it's
between them there's a third party it's
called the cat cat can't talk to us the
cat can't tell us please don't take off
my my fingers you know I'm sure that if
the cat actually could talk to us would
say yeah I I really want to keep my
fingers please so you know I
I I really urge you again please pass
something
anything all right thank you uh
representative H Haskins I'm sorry I
missed your name in town uh Christina
Snider I live in Chester New Hampshire
thank you thank you okay thank you for
your testimony today Michelle Fran and
Conroy you've asked for three minutes
it might not take as long as three
minutes either um I'm Michelle fransen
Conroy I'm a lifelong conquered resident
I'm here on behalf of myself um thank
you for having us be able to come here
and give
testimony um I'm here to talk about
firsthand knowledge of watching the
aftermath right after the cat has its
cat it claw declaw sorry um so I went to
school at UNH for a degree in animal
science and I had a job um right
afterwards at a local here in conquered
animal hospital and I worked out back
and I was in charge of cleaning the
kennels um checking on the animals after
surgery and I can't tell you how many
times that the they were mostly the
young cats getting declawed and they
would be all bandaged up have these big
bandages on them and they would be
wailing as they're coming out of the
anesthesia and they would be like kind
of banging their hands trying to get the
bandages off kind of out of it and the
cage would be full of blood like they
would manage to somehow get the bandages
off from scraping across it then they
would have to go take them and rebandage
them sometimes even another time after
that and it didn't happen one or two
times like it happens in most of the
cats they would just be wailing it was
just an awful sight and I mean blood
everywhere
so I mean that's going to make it even
worse trying to get that to heal up
because they're you know aggravating
that Sutra site and it just happened so
much and I just felt so bad for these
cats I don't know what the veterinarians
I never asked them about what they
thought of that cuz I'm sure they knew
that that was happening all the time um
but I just wanted to speak to that
firsthand knowledge of witnessing the um
cats right afterwards getting the the
cat declaw procedure done uh was just
horrible so please pass this Bill thank
you how long ago was that that you were
uh working in that um facility yeah I
didn't know if you wanted me to name the
facility but it was in conquered um it
was the early
1990s so I'm not sure if they still
perform it the same way I I mean there's
only so many ways you can cut to the
first knuckle I mean it's I would
imagine still the same procedure maybe
the bandaging is differently now but
thank you any
questions thank you for coming thank you
for your testimony today thank you uh
Tony
mclen good afternoon my name is Tony
mclen I'm a resident of New Hampshire
and I'm here today to voice my support
for HB 2011 it is an important bill and
the time has come the ban on declawing
needs to happen it's a cruel and
inhumane
practice and I know this firsthand so if
you can imagine your fingers being cut
off at the first knuckle and in many
cases it's the fingers and toes cut off
and then if you imagine you being sent
out there saying go live your life
this practice needs to stop and how do I
know that it's cruel and inhumane
because I've witnessed the surgery many
times and I've witnessed the outcome of
it I most of my career I've been a
wildlife biologist for 25 years so I
sought firsthand in wild cats and it
crippled them and killed them in many
cases some of them couldn't even get to
their water bowl and they died
crippled from this
procedure and in the case of domestic
animals I served as the Director of
operations for a very large animal
shelter taking in over 4,000 animals a
year and Contracting with 22 towns with
those 22 towns whether it was the Animal
control officer a veterinarian a police
officer or resident we could not say no
to that animal we had to take it in
and many of them were declawed cats
being returned this is not an N of one
this is an N of
thousands and I saw the
aftermath their paw the surgery as I
know it today is still a cut off at the
knuckle and it is still brutal many of
these animals were returned to the
shelter because they a very fear of well
scratching or biting my baby or my
toddler well they didn't before but they
did after so they were returned to the
shelter can't they're urinating
defecating outside the litter
box why because it's too painful to go
inside the litter
box the pain after the procedure some
with pain meds some without even with
constant pain medication the cat's
writhing in pain howling throughout
their lives so because I at the shelter
as director I would not euthanize these
cats I ended up with many of them and
they led a life of pain and again this
isn't an N of one it's an N of
thousands and it is cruel inhumane and
what does it say about us as a people as
a culture if we don't stop this cruel
inhumane treatment and there is that
provision in there that when it's
medically necessary go ahead and do
it all that is necessary as this quote
that I love so much goes all that is
necessary for evil to Prevail in this
world is for good people to do
nothing and I'll just end with there
there is data out there and I would be
happy to provide that not only what I
saw firsthand at the shelter thousands
because we took in many years almost
5,000 animals most of which were
cats so I'll just end with a quote from
the great Martin Luther King laws cannot
change Hearts but they can restrain the
heartless thank you for the opportunity
to
comment thank you any questions from the
committee representative
Scully thank you madam chair
excuse me thank you for coming and thank
you for sharing your testimony I was
very much interested in the perspective
of a shelter operator is it easier to
get a cat adopted with or without
claws it there are a lot of uh people
that ask for
declawing um or declawed cats so what I
implemented after seeing the effects of
declawing
I implemented a no adoption policy if
their intent was to declaw now could I
control that after they left the shelter
no but those cats often returned and
when they returned who wants to adopt a
cat that is urinating or defecating
outside the box or that's writhing in
pain or that has behavioral issues and
now they bite and scratch much more than
they did before no one so I ended up
with a lot of these cats and in many
shelters I refused to do it but in many
shelters they're euthanized so when the
word got out shelters started bringing
their cats to us because they knew we
wouldn't euthanize a declawed
cat followup yeah yeah thank you I I
wasn't precise in what I was asking you
you the cats that you had that had
already been declawed did people come in
and take them was there like did they
take those cats more than the clawed
ones the ones that still at Claws and
and the ones that did take the declawed
cats did they bring them back to you
because they found out they had problems
they weren't
anticipating I wouldn't say that more
adopted decla than and than that still
had their claws a lot of people ask for
declawed cats but um when discussing
what declaws did and seeing the cats
when they went to adopt them their
favorite cat maybe they wanted that
particular Main or what have you
when they saw their behavior or how they
reacted they didn't adopt them but more
I'm sorry the second part of your
question
again I didn't know if there was also a
a high return rate for people who did
take a declawed cat from your
shelter yes there was unfortunately yes
there was a high return rate thank
you I have a
question represent Venza do you still
work in that shelter now or how long ago
was this that you worked in the shelter
uh I worked in the shelter it's
been nine years no I recently retired as
the health inspector of the city of
Portsmouth no that was not and that was
right before that it was nine years ago
thank you representative Penza that was
my question okay there you go any other
questions from the committee thank you
for your testimony today thank you I
have one last comment I yearly I make a
point to call 8 to 10 veterinarians to
see just I'm a resident do you can I
declaw my cat and the answer most always
nine out of 10 is yes I
declaw thank
you uh call Lauren
Martin you asked for three minutes I'll
be quick most of what I wanted to say is
said thank
you um so my name is Lauren Martin I
live in Amherst New Hampshire um and I
am here to testify in support of hb21 I
have had cats my entire life um animals
in general I'm a big proponent of animal
welfare and I believe decla is inhumane
um more often than not the only reason
people seek to declaw their cat is due
to scratching and cats are constantly
growing and shedding their claws so if
that's just not something people can
deal with I think it's hard to at that
point own a cat but there are so many
Alternatives at this point that
declawing just shouldn't be necessary
you can get nail caps which go over the
claw they are dull they are rubber
they're not going to hurt you um you can
add more acceptable scratching surfaces
to your own home just routinely trimming
the claws yourself or your veterinarian
is so simple and so many hospitals
including Blue Pearl and the VCA have
banned declawing 42 countries and states
like Maryland New York most recently in
the past month Massachusetts have banned
it and I I think that's also another
point that should be brought up now that
Massachusetts is outlawing declawing
we're their border state if they want to
declaw and there are still people here
offering it those people are going to
come here to do it I think at this point
um it has been acknowledged that this is
inhumane and should not continue so I
greatly urge you to support hb21 thank
you any questions from the
committee thank you for your testimony
today a representative Christine silbert
oh she left okay uh Joan O'Brien New
Hampshire rights animals League New
Hampshire animal rights League
so thank you chair Aaron and members of
the committee for allowing me to
speak uh so I'm Joan O'Brien from
Amherst and I am uh here representing
the New Hampshire animal rights league
and we're in support of
hp21 uh the New Hampshire animal rights
League was formed almost 50 years ago in
1977 with the goal of protecting animals
from
harm retiring the declaw procceed
will not only protect countless cats
from disfigurement it might also save
the lives of some
veterinarians veterinarians face the
highest suicide rate of any profession
it's a high stress job takes an
emotional toll on them watching animals
suffer and
die and another contributing factor is
being forced to perform procedures that
you ethically oppose and in some
practices if the if the practice does
declaw you have to perform them because
you work
there and one Veterinary wrote on a
message board I think killing myself
might be the only way to stop the pain I
feel about declawing
cats so is it happening in New Hampshire
we've been discussing this quite a bit
um I don't know what number would be
enough we've had all sorts of anecdotal
uh numbers today uh the a 20 24 Wall
Street Journal article said that
22% of this country's 100 million cats
are
declawed some are here a random phone
survey that was done in 2023 of 20 vets
turned up five who declaw in New
Hampshire they're at the end of my
testimony and a few days ago I called uh
black rocks Veterinary Hospital in
Fremont and the woman who answered told
me that they do de
Clause so why don't we just wait for
this to go away on its own I mean you
know it's falling out of favor
right uh we can just keep educating and
just waiting um and as rep pretends are
brought up you know they don't teach it
in in vet school anymore but I think
that doing nothing would be a great
disservice to cats and our constituents
who are the more majority of are in
favor of of banning this
procedure enacting the law is essential
to send the powerful societal message
that decla is unacceptable and the law
is the most efficient way and expedient
way to just stop this
practice I I don't I'm not in favor of
some sort of an amendment about human
health only because the CDC um does not
recommend declawing in the case of imuno
compromised people or people on blood
thinners and and in addition that the
National Institutes of Health does not
recommend it and a few others that I
listed in my testimony they recommend
behavior
modification sometimes people will say
well isn't it better than you know the
cat getting euthanized I I think that's
a false dichotomy that comes up all the
time that there are other options it's
not an either
or if uh you know if you can't manage
the cat's
Behavior like for example you have a
child and the child keeps pulling the
cat's tail and the cat's going to
scratch them you ask yourself you know
is causing this cat pain and removing a
body part is is that what I want to do
or should I just give the cat a better
home a different
home and there was a study done in
British Colombia where they have banned
declawing that actually showed it was
done in
2022 that um the number of surrenders
after a cat's declawed uh it the number
of surrenders did not go did not change
and the number of owners decided to
euthanize actually went down after they
passed this ban for decline in British
Columbia one more Point uh will decline
be bad for business uh reportedly we
don't have enough veterinarians and vet
tax in New Hampshire to meet the the
demand um so removing decline from the
menu shouldn't put anybody out of
business and great positive note they
can do restruc reconstructive paw
surgery now so that could be um a new
service that veterinarians could offer
to fill out their their uh you know
their menu so thank you and uh please
support the bill so we can relegate this
debilitating surgery to a sad chapter in
Veterinary history thank you thank you
any questions from the
committee seeing
none thank you appreciate you coming
in uh one more pink card card today for
from Angela Ferrari from dog
owners and my apologies to those waiting
for the uh recess Bill uh that we had
earlier today we will get to that
shortly
hopefully I'll make it quick um so just
to reintroduce myself Angela Ferrari dog
owners of the granite state but I do
want to reiterate that we do have
membership who are cat owners and cat
breeders and they were definitely um
included in our position on this bill
which is that we do oppose it um a lot
of great information has already been
covered so I'm not going to go into my
full testimony I did pass out a copy but
I do want to remind everyone that the
medical professionals in the industry
with the veterinarians do need to
maintain their autonomy to also maintain
that vet patient relationship in making
these type of decisions
um in all of my own animal ownership I
take what my vet shares with me for
knowledge education
recommendation um to heart when we're
deciding what is appropriate for my cat
or my dog um I do think it's important
to reiterate that 8-year-old outdated
information or data shouldn't be
considered as part of this bill and that
more recent data as shared by the New
Hampshire VMA shows 20% or less per
forming uh these procedures when we did
our own calls to try and identify if
there were veterinarians uh just doing a
local call we did not find any who were
doing it so I think you know there's
definitely some data collection that
could be done um I do think that we
would support doing that type of
collection um to make sure that we're
making decisions based on facts because
over the past 5 years that we've heard
this bill this being the fourth time
we've never had that data and it's
always been very skewed and seemed that
there was very minimal procedures
happening in New Hampshire um I did want
to mention regarding the procedure just
to remove the nail itself that is
considered an onic ectomy and I probably
pronounced that wrong and that is listed
in here so that would be the newest
version of the ability to remove
strictly a claw without move removing
Knuckles or anything like that and doing
the gluing procedure um that would still
be banned as part of this
bill um I do also want to mention that
the av's position is that there's no
scientific evidence that decline leads
to behavioral abnormalities when it is
uh compared to cats outside of the
control group and that the survey that
they did only found 1% of cat owners
reported behavioral changes After
Decline so I think with Advanced
Technologies to do procedures properly
um they're not seeing the numbers that
were being seen in the 9s one the 90s
the procedures were a lot different and
it was a very popular procedure we've
seen humongous Decline and people even
being interested in the procedure let
alone the vets that are actually doing
the procedure at this time um so I don't
think we should be comparing data from
what people were seeing in the
9s um another in resting point you know
it's been mentioned that there's a lot
of declawed cats that end up in the
shelters in 2023 the Department of
Agriculture here in New Hampshire um the
commissioner reported that 15
1,596 cats were imported into the state
so I just want to raise that piece of
data for people to realize that if the
shelters are seeing an issue with
declawed cats in the shelters the
probability that those cats are coming
from Southern States where they're still
performing the procedure at high rates
that's likely why those cats are ending
up in New Hampshire shelters not because
the procedure is being done in New
Hampshire and people are relinquishing
their cats to the shelters and um two
last pieces one I don't think it's very
professional or appropriate for us to be
threatened here that this bill is going
to keep coming back if it doesn't make
it through this committee today we've
already seen it four times we don't want
to see it again but I don't think that
we should be making legislative
decisions because somebody says that
they're going to make us go through this
process again next year um and the last
thing dog owners of the granite state
does believe that this is a gateway bill
that is going to open up not only this
procedure down the road but other
procedures such as uh crop dock
artificial insemination debarking um and
then we get into the farming as well
we've got teeth nipping
dehorning um amongst other things so
this really is a gateway to just start
adding in other PE other procedures to
this bill and that continues to
deteriorate the professional autonomy of
the veterinarians and that that patient
relationship so with that I would take
any questions thank you representative
King thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking questions I'm really glad
that you're the last person um speaking
today um being an opponent of the bill
the reason why is because there's one
group of people that I found
interestingly absent today and that is
anybody who um has had this procedure
and just had fantastic results and said
that their cat lived happy healthy lives
painfree um why are there none of them
here today well I actually can speak to
that point I wanted to stick kind of to
the other type of facts but um when I
grew up in the '90s we had a who was
dclaw his name was Biffy and I have
mentioned him to this group before um at
prior bills but he lived a completely
normal happy life we never had any
issues with him uh he could climb trees
he could catch Chipmunks and he lived
into old age happily um we had other
cats that weren't declawed but for you
know whatever reason my father decided
that Biffy needed to be declawed but he
had no issues and he actually outlived
the other two cats that had claws
clearly not related but it didn't impact
his quality of life in anyway now we
don't decla our cats that we have we
haven't had a reason to um but that is
an example and if you would like to hear
from people who have had more positive
experiences I can reach out and try and
have them contact
you thank you representative
wheeler I just wanted to say I'm no
ComEd but I think it would be funny if
there was one here to make a joke about
the dog owners being opposed to the
catel
bill it's like Tom and Jerry we have cat
breeders and owners in I know and I
don't mean to disrespect your opposition
you brought up good testimony it gets
brought up each year because of the name
of our group
so thank you Kelly uh represent Penza
I'm
sorry it's okay Madam chair I do that
stuff all the time um just a quick
question because um it was based upon
the numbers that you gave in regards
with the shelters taking in you know
1500 some OD from
um why not part of the reporting piece
that we're you know that a lot of us are
talking about so we could actually have
hard facts wouldn't it be great to
encorporate right now today
2025 how many cats are in shelters and
how many are declawed whether they you
know and of course they'll know if it's
a New Hampshire cat or if it's if it
came from another state with wouldn't
that be great information for us to all
have to make our
decisions I mean I don't see why not as
long as you know we're we do know where
that cat came from who was declaw
because I think we would see that it's
not a New Hampshire issue it's not
something that's being done in New
Hampshire creating a problem in shelters
for New Hampshire that those cats are
being imported in but it would
definitely be a valid piece of
data thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you very much for
coming today this afternoon um can I get
the blue sheet for um for this uh
hearing and I want to just report that
uh from the online portal testimony
shows 152 people in support of this bill
and 95
opposed for the blue sheet we have one
two three four five people
opposed
three three six seven people four and
with that I'm going to close the hearing
on uh hb21 prohibiting the removal of
clause from cats I am going to reopen
the hearing for HB
215 uh requiring a landfill permit
applicant to submit a report listing
potential harms and benefits of the
project so we're going to switch
gears I am going
to okay okay thank
you um I'm going to invite up um
director
whimet as he was the last person to
testify and I believe uh the committee
may have had some further questions
regarding um
getting um potential harms and benefits
reports for pro pro projects being
considered uh for landfill permits so
did anybody from the committee have any
further
questions representative
guber thank you for coming back thank
you for thank you so much for um
rearranging your schedule and coming
back and I my sincere apologies for uh
being yet another half hour late thank
you madam chair uh so I just had one or
two more questions um I'll ask you one
is we were just about to speak about the
issue of um in the legis draft
legislation of of appointing a
independent third party to do this
analysis of of the uh net public
benefit and it doesn't say who would
hire this this firm or individual in in
the draft legislation so I was going to
ask you your thoughts about whe whether
that uh it does say that would be paid
for by the contractor so my question to
you do you think it'd be best for Dees
to um be the person who chooses this
person to do this analysis that's um in
line I don't have line numbers I guess
here that's under
d uh second
line line 14 line
14 yeah I thank you for the question
question I agree with you it's not clear
from the language in the bill who
actually selects or hires that person as
as I read it now um again is what it
suggests is that a third party um
independent third party would conduct it
on behalf of the host Community or other
AB budding municipalities so I I I don't
want to speak I don't know what the
sponsor's intent was so I'm not sure I
know the answer to that do you think so
you don't know whether it' be best for
the hency to choose the individual or
the uh part that's being um uh
requesting to permit I guess I would be
a little concerned about the agency
selecting I I don't know how much or if
we have any expertise and and or
knowledge about the sort of Consulting
community that might be likely to do
that kind of work um you know there's
never a perfect way to do this if if the
agency were to select a particular
company based on whatever criteria were
provided um some some people would
probably be happy with that selection
and others might not depending on
whether they thought it was a good
selection or not um right now I'm not
sure that I really know
[Music]
who what companies and what what what
what sector of the uh Private Industry
you know would be qualified to do this
work have a quick followup that's okay
quick followup sure quick followup is
that that uh I thought the same thing
over lunch and uh and I was found out
three groups for example uh Society of
risk analysis Society for benefit cost
analysis or the National Association of
environmental professionals groups like
that I'm sure you know of many of these
groups could they be helpful at kind of
identifying a pool of contractors that
actually have the capacity to do the
work properly I I suspect they could
sure I don't have personal knowledge
that but I I'd anticipate that folks
like that would have some good ideas
okay thanks okay questions
representative
K thank you madam chair and thank you
director for being here again this
afternoon um so I've been going through
the bill and I have a question for you
and I'm having a hard time defining
something net public benefit can you
explain to me what that
means no I can't I mean again I I didn't
draft the bill so I don't know what is
intended and I don't want to speak for
the sponsor or the drafter um my
understanding from reading the bill is
that it's it's an attempt to get a
broader perspective on the possible
benefits associated with the sighting of
a facility right now as we discussed
earlier in the hearing um the uh the
statute really looks at kind of three
things does does the proposed facility
meet some kind of uh calculated capacity
need for waste disposal is it consistent
with the uh provisions of the solid
waste management plan and is it
consistent with the hierarchy um or does
it help to advance the hierarchy of
Waste Management preferred options this
seeks to as I read it to include a
broader perspective of looking at
possible uh harms or benefits that might
be associated with the facility that go
beyond just providing capacity or being
consistent with the state's plan for
managing solid waste and goes to more
really local and Regional Community
issues like um you know economic impacts
noise um traffic Transportation
issues thank you representative
Howard thank you madam chair um I used
to work with planners and we would send
out rfps to for to get Consultants to
help us on projects and to you know to
broaden our expertise and to me this
seems like an opportunity for Dees to to
talk to somebody who doesn't do exactly
what you do but what I wonder about is
how much would you
um how much would you prioritize like
the benefits over the harm or you know
how how would you assess you know sort
through the the information that you get
that's a great question that's a
question that we've asked ourselves in
reading this bill and I don't I don't
think the bill really goes quite goes
there or gives any clear guidance on how
you would it doesn't say it's a class
benefit analysis it doesn't say that it
doesn't say how to you know it doesn't
provide any kind of basis for scoring
various benefits versus V various harms
so it's really difficult to say what how
how whether it's the agency or some
other party how that would be uh an
analyzed followup yep so um could you
make suggestions on how how to PR you
know sort of what information would be
important to you and how you would prior
prioritize it in order to improve the
bill um well I guess you know just right
here and now with your question I I I'm
not prepared to tell you here's how you
should score it and here's what wins and
what doesn't but certainly I I think you
know as as permit as a perming Authority
the agency has had to make difficult
decisions in the past and there have
certainly have been times where um
issues and and and impacts Beyond uh the
the scope of what the agency's charged
with evaluating have been a concern that
have been expressed um by the community
members or or others and um I think that
that's why our testimony is that we do
think that a broader look at some of
these impacts is is is is indicated and
is important and we're willing to work
with the legislature to try to sort out
what that might look
like thank you representative
Penza just quickly because I'm a
co-sponsor of the bill that the
intention is for it to be uh the person
that's putting in a permit to um not
Dees to though go find the Independent
party it would be the responsibility of
that but I'm sure it could be the
committee could amend that to that I
also just my question here is there's so
many things that are in this paragraph
that talk about things that are in your
prw so that's right it from your
previous testimony it looks as if you
were staying that the State's
Department the state's environmental
Department doesn't have a single person
in its building that's actually capable
of reading not not writing just reading
a report that discusses the harms of an
environmental project is that true no I
first I'll say
everyone I've worked with the Department
is an excellent reader so we're
certainly capable of reading um those
things and I don't I'm glad you asked
the question because I don't want it to
sound like everything in that paragraph
described describes areas that we're not
qualified to evaluate in fact many of
the things in that paragraph are
specifically addressed in in the
directives the legislature has given us
and in the administrative rules that
we've uh Advanced to that we have a
direct um responsibility to evaluate
those things and those things would
include groundwater and surface water
pollution um and you know air emissions
from the facility we absolutely look at
those things and we're I think well
positioned to do that and I'm not
suggesting that that this bill should uh
take that away from the department and
give it to a different group what I'm
suggesting is there are areas outside of
our areas of expertise that would
benefit from the expertise of others
other than Department
employees okay representative H Haskins
thank you madam chair and thank you
director whimet so would you think then
if we did the CBA with people who are
organized to do cost benefit analysis
analyses and that we have the expertise
of the department and the permits that
have to be acquired for air and water um
that we could uh together um and I like
uh representative Howard's RFP idea um
get some names and review uh those names
and put together the CBA with the um
environmental impact that your
department is surely authorized and um
able and ready to do that we could put
together something that would help us do
this benefit versus harm again I'm
trying to get at the forest for the
trees you know some of us believe that
we need more um data for the harms that
any project could befall and does that
sound reasonable to you it does I think
that's been my testimony today and and I
think that I do want to clarify though
that um depending on what circles you
travel in a cost benefit analysis means
a very particular thing and I don't
think that's what this bill is in
envisioning cost benefit usually implies
you can think of cost in a broader sense
but often when you talk about a cost
benefit analysis it's looking at what is
the dollar value of what it's going to
cost for a particular project and then
again weigh that against some assigned
dollar value to the benefits and I don't
think that's what this bill is trying to
do it is an analysis of benefits and
potential harms and and somehow
Reckoning between them to figure out
whether a facility ought to be it or not
but I don't think it's actually a cost
benefit analysis Madam chair followup
followup and would there not be cost to
the harms as well oh I'm not not
suggesting that you couldn't do it I'm
just saying that my understanding of the
bill is that it doesn't seek to do what
traditionally is called a cost benefit
analysis that's all it's
justan thank you I have a question and
then uh representative Scully so my
question
is in this new paragraph I mean there's
there are many areas where your
department is certainly qualified to
make a determination of harms versus
benefits but for the parts that they
perhaps are
not would it be uh a good idea as part
of this bill and as an amendment or
whatever that you would seek someone
outside of the department probably an
independent contractor that you can do
an R f p on and
then charge that work the cost of that
work to the
applicant is that something that you
could see as a
workable thing I think that is a that
that's one construct that you could use
I don't think that's what I've suggested
here in my testimony what I've suggested
in my testimony is exploring the idea of
a separate decision-making body that
would act um first as part of a two-part
decision-making process um but certainly
depending on how we're determined to to
work best you know there are there are
other examples of the agency having the
authority to um hire outside experts to
advise it in in its permanent processes
and so that's certainly something I
think when you do that do you normally
Bill whoever it is you're working with
to if the statute gives us the authority
to do that yes that's what we would okay
good to
know representa Scully thank you madam
chair now if I remember the testimony of
the um
sponsor he had said there were 16 other
states that are basically are now
currently employing this type of
approach for
evaluation um so I would assume there's
16 different templates potential
templates to review and perhaps draw
from to create something that we think
would be workable for us has your agency
done this in the past in terms of going
look at how other people have done it
and put together um using you know
rather than Reinventing the wheel
completely using what's been done before
and come up with something that's best
for us sure there's certainly a number
of regulatory approaches we've taken
where we looked at surveyed what other
states were doing to try to get ideas or
to figure out what works well and what
doesn't I think as to the first part of
your your question and I don't want to
speak for the sponsor but what I took
from the sponsor's testimony was he was
I thought he was speaking about 16 other
states that have something like a
Federal Environmental a nepo policy
National Environmental Policy Act
environmental impact statement and
assessment process I don't I didn't
think he was talking specifically about
for decisions about landfills but I I
don't want to testify for him
so representative guber uh yes uh first
clarification I think he was referring
to the NEPA process in the other states
but not the same uh my my question is um
does dees currently have legal is
legally permitted to consider all harms
and adverse uh impacts during your
permitting process are you limited to
certain things and this would allow you
to look at other things that are not
currently
permitted I I I I do think that the
statute gives us pretty clear Direction
on what areas we're to be evaluating in
what and and and leaves out areas other
areas and so this I think would it's a
little unclear the way draft but it it
implies at least that the agency would
be able to consider
additional potential harms outside the
scope of what we currently have
Authority for yes this quick and what
sort of areas were they uh what sort of
areas would you that add to your
permitting process that you you can
consider if this was well I guess if you
if I understand your question if you
read the bill to say that the um the
independent third party analysis that's
described red in lines 12 through 20 um
which includes um noise odor traffic um
and uh emissions and transport uh
impacts related to um transportation to
the facility um those would be I think
areas that we have we have some limited
ability we we we regulate noise and odor
the the current rules say that noise and
odor has to be limited to the extent
practicable but it doesn't really give
us us um specific authority to evaluate
noise or odor impacts in the context of
a permit decision whether that's yay or
nay um and then um you know I I think
that actually and then traffic would be
another one we we we do have authority
to evaluate traffic impacts very
localized to the facility but it's not
clearly it's not clear that we really
have authority to look at traffic
impacts that are further of healed from
the facility thank you very much okay
any other
questions seeing none thank you very
very much for rearranging your schedule
again to come back and testify and that
goes for everybody else who's come back
I I really appreciate that you've uh
hung in there for us um with that I'd
like to call Amy
maneli that's from North Country
Alliance for balance CH change thank you
good afternoon
again there we go uh good afternoon
Madam chair I do have two hard copies
there and I did just email the committee
during our break so you have all that
digitally uh my name is Amy manzelli and
I'm here on behalf of the North Country
Alliance for balance change to testify
in support of HB
215 um I did just want to go over some
of the technicalities here I have
reviewed and analyzed the as introduced
I haven't seen the proposed amendment um
we're in favor of you know the language
getting word smithed some of the
concepts getting tinkered with and
improved um but we are not in favor of
an amendment that would result in a
study committee so I just kind of wanted
to set that
forward um as I was thinking about sort
of uh the RSA 49m which of course is the
statute that this bill Tinkers with you
know it daunted on me that big statutes
like this they're like all of our homes
you know the to-do list is never done I
look back over um the legislative
history and I found I want to get the
number right here uh you all have
amended this Statute in seven of the
past eight years so you're tinkering
you're tinkering you're tinkering you're
making it better but just like that
to-do list at home it's never done it's
never going to be perfect um and so HB
215 it's just another opportunity to
make RSA 149 M even better and I want to
go over some of the points point about
how it does that uh obviously you've
heard um just now and then earlier today
the Crux of that is this net public
benefit changing uh the language so it's
a net public benefit not just public
benefit we're not just going to stack up
the benefits and see if they're enough
we're going to stack up the harms and
we're going to do a balancing test um so
the first thing that this statute this
if this bill were enacted the statute
would do is it would make what is a very
sensible
clarification that it's only the
facility applied for that can make
enough benefits to be permitted so if
it's a solid waste facility
expansion then it's that expansion that
needs to be analyzed it's not the
applicants
other facility at a different part of
the state that can generate the
benefits that would justify an expansion
at the facility being applied for so
that's one of the changes we're talking
when we're adding up the benefits and
the harms and we're looking at the net
public benefit we're only thinking about
the harms and the benefits of the
facility being applied for so that's
number number one um number two and this
came up with um director whims Hat's
testimony I wanted to make sure that the
committee is aware this the approach
that this bill uses is based on well
settled New Hampshire law and the two
examples that I've given you here are uh
with zoning boards of adjustment when
they consider a
variance one of the variance criteria
which is set in state law and I have the
citation there for you it's you know 674
33 Roman 1 12C um is that substantial
justice has to be done this is a
balancing test that
means any loss to the applicant that is
not outweighed by a gain to the general
public so you're balancing the harms and
the benefits of a project in the context
of a variance if you're sitting as the
zoning board
and just like as proposed in this bill
the zoning board has the authority to
hire its own Consultants to assess the
harms and benefits of the project now I
know we there was discussion earlier
that this bill envisions the applicant
doing the hiring of the independent
third party it's a little bit of a
distinction without a difference in my
view because I've seen this unfold
hundreds of times it's a collaborative
approach the applicant and whatever the
decision-making body is be it a zoning
board planning board site evaluation
committee what have you they work
together to identify the consultant to
identify the scope of work the scope of
work is going to say what the consultant
is going to do when they're going to do
it how much it's going to cost all of
that is pre-agreed upon because the
applicant does not want to pay for it
only to find out that the decision maker
wanted a little bit something different
so they work together collaboratively to
get the study done and then the
application is
processed the other thing I wanted to
highlight here is RSA 162 H this is the
sighting statute for energy generation
in transmission facilities the site
evaluation committee sort of like a
Statewide zoning board for power plants
and transmission lines same thing they
have the power to um hire their own
experts and they routinely do so this
sort of concept it works really well now
I also wanted to mention the site
evaluation committee citing laws because
of another aspect there that is similar
to what is proposed
here that law recognizes you don't even
have to debate about it it just
recognizes that energy transmission and
energy generation projects have adverse
effects they just do okay we're just
going to everybody comes to the table
with that acknowledgement we're not even
going to try to pretend that they don't
the key in that statute is if the
project has
unreasonable adverse effects you're not
going to get a certificate of
site if the applicant can show that you
don't this the lawyer double negative if
you don't have unreasonable adverse
effects then you get your certificate of
sight and that's what hp215 seeks to do
let's just acknowledge an expanded or a
new solid waste facil facility is going
to have adverse effects so let's balance
it up and make sure the ones that are
cited are the ones that have a net
public benefit just like some of our
other well settled New Hampshire
law and then lastly I just wanted to
talk about the Capac need um I think
this was brought up earlier this is a
direct response from the invitation from
the New Hampshire Supreme Court in a
December
2023 uh decision where the New Hampshire
Supreme Court said you know uh we have
one party here who says capacity need
means you know you have to the landfill
the solid waste applicant has to show
that the landfill is needed every second
of every day of every year for its
entire ire operational Lifetime and the
other side said uh no you know we we
just have to show like it's needed for
one day um HB 215 rejects these polar
opposite positions and takes a middleof
the road Common Sense approach and it
says the applicant just us to show that
you are filling a need for solid waste
disposal half the time that you're going
to be
operating so it considered these two
polar opposite positions that were
involved in that lawsuit and it chose
you know right down the middle of the
road
approach that's what I have for the
committee today um it's all documented
in the letter that I submitted in your
record I would welcome questions thank
you thank you so much um I really
appreciate you laying out a lot of these
points for US Representative Bixby yes
thank you Chair for My taking my
question thank you um Miss maneli
Mani okay um that should be a little bit
better um so uh thinking about I I like
your explanation of the way that um we
already have a model for getting uh EXT
outside consultants in New Hampshire law
and I'm wondering if you think that the
bill as introduced needs to clarify that
portion of how it works a little a
little bit
better as I read the bill I do see that
it is ambiguous as to who would be doing
that whether the applicant or the agency
um but I did hear and I I keyed into the
sponsor's explanation that the intention
was to not constrain the agency um and
when you learn administrative law in law
school they give you this analogy that
administrative law is like a paint by
numbers and you all the lawmakers you
pick the colors and you make the shapes
and you fill in the numbers of where the
colors are supposed to go but the
agencies actually paint the painting
they have to paint within the boundaries
and they have to use the colors that you
set forth um but they get to do the
painting and so I took that to mean that
it was the sponsor's intention that the
agency would fill in those details with
the ru
making thank you representative King
thank you madam chair and thank you for
your testimony today um I hope my
question is appropriate but I've got
your written testimony here and I'm just
curious because in the letter head it
says BCM environmental and land law pllc
but then you're representing North
Country Alliance for balance change can
you just explain why like what what what
the relationship between the two of
those are and also just a little bit
about what North Country Alliance for
balance change is all about I hope that
question is appropriate
I'll allow it if it's brief than sure um
I am the attorney for North Country
Alliance for balance change uh BCM
environmental and land law is my Law
Firm that's where I'm employed uh and
ncbc is my longtime client um uh I'm
going to punt on the what NC ABC is
about because we have one of their um
folks here who can do a better
explanation on that than I can but
generally they are a nonprofit
organization advocating for a balance in
our development and uh preserving the
North
Country thank you for that
representative Howard thank you madam
chair um sort of that was a great
explanation thank you so much so much
clarification for me um as about halfway
through you said you know what if you
meet the criteria for
for benefits like if the benefits
outweigh the harm then you get the
permit I mean is that is it an automatic
is it or or do you just get to advance
to making your application um that I was
referencing I believe the unreasonable
adverse effects which is the language
used in RSA 162 which governs the
sighting of energy transmission
facilities and generation or
transmission and generation facilities
um I was simplifying it is not a simple
process just like the process for
obtaining a solid waste permit currently
it's a complicated at process and
there's a um rather short set of
statutory standards and then there's an
elaborate set of rules that support
those and so there's a lot of boxes um
to be checked off and I don't mean to
use a check off the Box analogy to say
that it's not qualitative because it's
quite qualitative there are lots of
reports lots of analysis that go into
the approval
but yes if you can demonstrably satisfy
no unreasonable effect then your project
should be
permitted followup
yet could you say that phrase again that
like no no what sure no
unreasonable adverse
effect thank you yep and in the statute
that that contains all that is
referenced in my letter if you want to
look it up
represent
Penza I would love you to thank you
madam chair I would love you to speak
briefly um on what you just said because
I think it's so important um from
previous testimony that we've had to
make this clear that when a when someone
is putting in their permit
application there these things aren't
looked at in the sense of uh for any
sort of public benefit net public
benefit let's say air pollution for one
all they're doing is checking off a box
saying that we're following federal law
correct can you can you speak to that
how it's not we're not looking at we're
just it's it's not an analysis of all
these other entities it's just basically
saying okay yeah we're going to follow
federal law yep um yes thank you for the
question it it is a little bit tricky
you know um because for example there is
an air Resources Division at the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services and I'm sure that this bill is
not saying duplicate the exact same work
that the air Resources Division is doing
again um I think what this Bill is
saying and I think director whim hat um
did a good job explaining this the
current law really lays out um three
areas which you could think about as
three
constraints does the solid waste
facility meet a capacity need you know
is is there are we all generating trash
which we all do and there's no more hole
to put it in and it can't be recycled it
can't be composted Etc it needs to be
landfilled so is there a capacity need
um as you all know especially this
committee there is a solid waste
management plan so does this project
satisfy whatever that says at the
current time and there's the solid waste
hierarchy which I mentioned in my
letter um Source reduction Recycling and
reuse composting waste to energy
incineration without resource recovery
and then last call landfilling so does
this project satisfy that
hierarchy the department is constrained
you know from considering things outside
of that so um you know a rather
humorous example is like well what about
the seagulls you know what about the the
noise and the nuisance and the excrement
of
seagull like that's a real
impact is that something that the
department can
consider you know um and director whim
touched on a couple others you know
traffic um the Department of
Transportation is probably going to be
implicated in any project expansion or
new project because there's likely going
to need a need to be a new or amended
driveway permit but the Department of
Transportation is likely not going to be
considering uh noise or emissions
especially Statewide or the leate
hauling aspects of what's going to be in
the trucks so there's a lot that is
worthy of consideration that the
department is not under current law
arguably empowered to
consider
okay any other
questions no thank thank you so very
much for your testimony today thank you
all we really appreciate your work on
this and I'd like to call Henry veu from
Waste
Management then we have two more thank
you madam chair uh and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Henry veu and I'm here on behalf of
Waste
Management um which owns and operates
the turkey landfill in
Rochester um we took uh members of the
committee out there last spring uh not
everyone was able to attend and I know
there are new members on this committee
um we'd be happy to uh do another tour
this spring uh I think it's uh
informative um but I'm just here to
speak about uh the impact of this bill
on an existing landfill like uh the tury
landfill in Rochester um it's a
1455 Acre Site um Waste Management has
been operating it since
1983 so they've been operating it there
for over 40 years um it has permitted
capacity uh that will take us to
2034 or more um the permit
requires uh it to be open until June of
2034 for but the way they've been
managing uh and depleting uh its
capacity it will likely uh last a little
longer uh than
2034 um it has undeveloped land at that
site that could uh they could
expand uh which would bring its life
into the following decade um if they
wanted to expand they would have to go
through uh the process of getting a
permit and going through this public
benefit um process uh they've gone
through it six times in the 40 years uh
and able they have been able to
demonstrate a public benefit there has
been a need for uh the capacity uh and I
think representative Jana uh uh director
whims out and um attorney miselle
explained what's involved in the current
public benefit demonstration um the
department the statute directs the
department to look at a 20-year
Horizon and determine whether over that
next 20 years we have enough capacity to
put New Hampshire generated trash into
uh the facility um it also requires them
to look in uh context of the
hierarchy um land filling is down the
bottom uh you know it's reuse uh uh
there are a number of other uh ways to
manage it uh and it also has to compare
it to the solar Waste Management plan so
right now um if uh the tury
landfill wants to
expand and extend the life of that
facility which they currently can do
Beyond 2034 35 uh they would have to go
through this process and so
bill um would apply in that instance um
and looking at the new language uh in
bold on lines 12 through 20 of the bill
uh Waste Management would have to uh pay
for um an
assessment uh to be
conducted uh to
determine the potentially harmful
impacts on human health property values
tourism
outdoor recreation and Wildlife and it
further states that such impacts may be
uh noise odor traffic groundwater
pollution surface water pollution
greenhouse gas and emissions from
transport of solid waste uh and what I'm
trying to say today is that all these
conditions currently exist and they've
existed at that site for 40 years and so
just question in the utility and the
value of doing this assessment on an
existing
facility um the noise will probably be
the same the odor will probably be the
same the traffic transporting the waste
will be the same and so um I just
question whether there's any value and
utility and imposing this on a facility
uh that's been around for 40 years and
is looking to expand um and that's
basically uh my testimony for
today thank you um yeah representative
wheeler thank you chairwoman Aon
so would you say now I guess I'll ask my
first question which would be you said
that
the you have been able to D demonstrate
benefit over the course of the last 40
years my first question would be is that
analysis available to the public where
that had been done can the public look
at what those assessment looks like from
Dees and maybe from the town uh where
your facility is that'd be my first
question yeah so RSA 149 M11 the public
benefit requirement um it lists in here
uh What uh it directs the department to
do to figure out whether there is that
public benefit um I'm assuming that all
of that is all public record uh and
available um through the through the
state yes I'm sorry followup y thank you
madam chair the followup I would have is
given the fact that we heard testimony
that the statute has changed seven times
in eight years and I imagine it's
changed a DEC amount over the course of
the last 40 years don't you think it
would behoove a facility or I guess
rather don't you think that uh it would
be necessary for a facility if it was
going to go through an expansion given
the fact how much rules change over 40
years to have to go through an analysis
like that I'm not saying we shouldn't
have to go through the public benefit
analysis what I'm saying is that the new
uh condition
and uh things that assessment the
assessment that is being called for in
this
bill uh doesn't really seem to uh apply
to an existing facility where all those
conditions currently exist that's all
one more followup the final followup I
would have is I guess maybe we could
flush this out on in the email exchange
or something like that but I I I guess I
don't necessarily see how any of those
conditions outlined in the bill wouldn't
apply to a facility that is currently
existing pollution air noise all those
things things like uh property values
those properties are already next to the
facility okay um it they know it could
expand so I'm sure real those impacts
are already they already exist we don't
have to have someone make an assumption
that if you bring this thing in it's
going to drop property values or
whatever because those properties the
impact is already there okay uh and and
the traffic the trucks going in to the
facility they'll probably be the same
the number of older complaints you can
look over 40-year history and get a
sense of what they are and um we're
going to do a heck of a lot better job
at at addressing those but uh I think
the things that this bill is calling for
um are already known in an existing
facility okay and and maybe that part of
you know the benefit this net public
benefit um doesn't really need to be
conducted
on because I think largely the
Consultants will say what's existed for
40 years are probably going to continue
to exist over the next 10 years this
facility is there and is there a lot of
value when doing that okay um
representative Penza and then
representative H
Haskins uh thank you madam chair um and
uh thank you for taking my question so
um I agree with you and I'm of course uh
representative in Rochester um so I'm
very familiar with uh the uh the
landfill uh TurnKey so um so basically
we're saying that the we already know
what the impacts are and we know what
they've been over 40 years so I agree
with you I don't think this is necess
this is necessary for for that but just
based upon like your experience um in
the field for let's say a brand new
landfill that's going in um do you feel
like these the criteria that's in here
um is can be identified it's is clear so
um you're you're asking about a facility
uh where none exists a proposal for
facility none exist uh a
hypothetical um and uh I would say that
um certainly you could measure that
stuff I think you could hire Consultants
to tell you how much traffic will
probably best estimated to go there um
maybe the impact on uh uh uh the homes
around there and whatnot
um that uh is something that doesn't
exist ex right now so there might be
some utility in that um certainly more
utility than doing it for a site where
we already know what those are but you
certainly can hire
Consultants uh the communities could
hire Consultants to come up
with uh their best guess yeah follow up
follow up in regards with TurnKey and
let's say um you get to that
2034 2035 asking for uh 2 or three year
um extension or an expansion um it's
helpful for you because you're just
saying that these impacts are measurable
we have a 40-year history um those
impacts probably really wouldn't
increase much like let's say for
Rochester so all of the other things
that you already do as a company with
notifications and all that would already
be in place and all of these people
would already know these impacts correct
yes representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair so I'm trying to understand
the nature of expansion if if a landfill
is expanded and you say the impacts are
already known we have more trucks we
have more odor we have more traffic
wouldn't expanding the
footprint the phrase that comes to my
mind is when you know better you do
better so now we know a lot more about
that than we did 20 years ago so
wouldn't the same benefit apply to an
expansion given that we now can assess
new
technology helps us to assess some of
those
factors so um because they have a
40-year history there um and they've
gone through six
expansions um we know the number of
trucks that are going in there uh we
have to log uh and and have known all
those years
um again I think the there'll be very
little change because we'll be closing
down a portion of the
landfill that we won't be able to fill
anymore and just
when they go to apply for a permit they
didn't apply for the permit for all,
1455 Acres they do it in bite sizes and
so the expansion that would occur and
the use of that would probably be about
equal to what the previous small bite
size was and so in that regard there
won't be a lot of difference that that's
what I'm trying to say I see thank you
representative K than thank you madam
shair and uh thank you for taking my
question but first off I'd like to say
thank you uh for the field trip last
spring for anyone that has not gone on
it it was eye openening I was absolutely
amazed so I just wanted to thank and
thank you for inviting us back um I do
have a question for you and I do
understand after going on that field
trip what you're talking about with odor
and things like that you're closing up
one and adding another section as the
expansion
my question to you is you stated that
current capacity right now is to 2034 is
that correct that's correct we are the
permit requires us to keep it open until
2034 so you know there's a lot of talk
about outstate trash we turn away a lot
of out ofate trash because we have to
guarantee for the State of New Hampshire
a place to put that trash until 2034 so
we have to monitor how much trash goes
in there okay
um
and if you need to once you are getting
close to how long does it take for a
process to happen to expand further what
is that process so they will have to
begin soon I mean 2034 sounds like a
while down the road but they are going
to have to begin soon uh getting ready
to submit because
otherwise if they don't the permit yet
and the other and the section is full
there's going to be a period of time
where there will be a heck of a lot less
capacity in the state and so it's uh
soon one more I I I
guess what is the time frame is it is it
a three-year time frame is it a
four-year time frame let me get that
exactly from Steve pudy he he that's
what he does thank and I'll uh send an
email to the committee thank you so much
thank you represent
thank you for taking my question so
um uh you you you have not directly said
this but I'm wondering whether uh what
you would prefer or what what your or
the organization you represent would
prefer would be to Simply have a waiver
for existing uh as expansions of
existing landfills or whether it be be
some sort of modification where all of
the current data that is known uh such
as the traffic rates the Odor Control
Etc would be uh filed as like a a
baseline uh I think we'd prefer just to
be Exempted out that that existing
facilities the utility of this
information uh you know the exercise of
going through this not the we already
have the information is what I'm saying
and so um uh hiring Consultants to do it
um
so is that is that information that you
um that you already submit to Dees as as
uh for documentation along the way and
you're like so do you submit to them
reports on traffic and on odor
complaints Etc no okay thank you
represent
Penza thank you madam chair um just
because I'm in Rochester I'd like to
answer and ask a question as well um I
have to say that we management does a
fantastic job of communicating with the
constituents even constituents that are
very angry whether it be about odors and
all of that um would you be amenable if
there is in a sense like a carve out for
an extension to be able to provide you
know the information that we you know on
record not saying you have to go hire a
$50,000 consultant because like I said
everybody kind of knows especially in
Rochester what's going on but I think
that people like to see that what you
just said people don't realize like
they're thinking a big huge footprint
not just it's expanding so the one
closes and all of that kind of stuff
would you be willing to still have that
information come out to the public all
of the surrounding areas that are
affected by the landfill yeah I mean we
know the trucks the number of trucks
that are coming in and out uh there's no
secret about that we can you know share
that information um I think the
department I suspect they record when
people people uh complain about odors
and so I think there's probably a log of
that uh so that's known um other
information about there you know the the
the real estate
values those are known so I mean to your
question
um I don't think we need to hire someone
to do an assessment to get all that
stuff that it's already
available representative wheeler thank
you madam chair
so if you don't need to hire somebody to
do it is that information already
available to the public are you as
representative gerana or Bixby said are
you already providing that information
to D Dees so how could we access that
information I uh to your answer your
question if someone wanted to get it
they'd probably have to invest a little
time and go look for it I mean because
it's not probably in packaged in one
nice neat little place um but the
information is available um and
yeah so okay representative H Haskins
thank you madam chair so I'm still stuck
on this expansion thing so would a
potential expansion be the exact
footprint of a part of the landfill that
you had already closed down you mean the
number of acres and whatnot uh obvious
they vary a little bit um I would think
um but we would know I mean the the
department will want to
just as they have with the expansions to
date
um get some sort of
guarantee uh because right now the
primary public benefit measurement is do
we need the capacity and so they're
going to want to hold you to keep to to
maintaining that
capacity uh and so like with every
permit to date there will likely be we
want that room and capacity there until
X date and then you could do
calculations about the number of uh you
know dumps that could be uh deposits of
trash um this information could be
gathered
um followup Madam followup y um so we're
trying to get in this
bill what
um Miz Manel called The Balancing Act
Right Between benefits and harms so I'm
not yet clear that an analysis shouldn't
be done for an expansion given it's on
the other side of the, 1400 Acres there
are other people living off that end in
that direction um I think it would be
useful for an expansion and and I
thought I heard you say that the
community communities could hire
Consultants but of course we don't think
the communities should bear the burden
of the cost is that
clear uh I was just referring to the
bill so it says that
um there's an assessment shall be
conducted on behalf of the host
community and other abing municipalities
right on behalf of the communities not
by the communities right they they and
as was described it probably be the
department with the Pere the applicant
uh is going to bear the cost yeah the
applicant would bear the cost um exactly
and U uh a consultant would be found
sure thank
you any other questions from the
committee one more okay
um so just uh just a
basic question so um do you believe that
in in the next 20 years that the
landfill would be would provide right
right now based upon the criteria that
you know would be more of a public
benefit than a harm in with TurnKey
yes simple question simple answer thank
you thank you so
much I'd like to call Nancy Morrison
okay sure
okay um well it's good afternoon now my
paperwork said good
morning thank you for it's morning
somewhere yes there you go I'll try to
keep this as brief as possible you've
heard a lot already and it's late um did
I hear earlier that someone did ask who
NC ABC
is okay um I a member of
ncbc I'm not a board
member uh the president and the vice
president are usually here for these
meetings but both of them could not be
here
today um but briefly ncbc stands for
North Country Alliance for balance
change and it is a volunteer Grassroots
organization I brought this up
here it was founded in 20 2008 in the
belief that a healthy economy in
Northern New Hampshire depends on a
healthy
environment and they have three main
goals they're working toward stopping a
massive landfill from fing the North
country that would be sitting near
pristine Forest Lake and in the middle
of the amonk river Watershed one of New
Hampshire's highest rated Wildlife
areas uh ncbc advocates for Clean Water
and Air climate protection and public
health as well as Solid Waste Management
reform and they advocate for um
education for New Hampshire residences
and visitors that's brief um you can go
to their website of course if you want
to learn more and I can try to answer
any questions you'd have but that's a
brief
summary is that
good
okay um so again good afternoon Madam
chair woman Aaron and honorable members
of this committee the house environment
and agriculture committee for the record
my name is Nancy Morrison and I have
residences in both Whitefield and Mont
Vernon New Hampshire I would like to
First express my gratitude to this
committee for your continued willingness
to engage and work to improve how New
Hampshire manages Solid Waste through
your
diligence awareness and progress has
been accomplished but as you can see
from House Bill 2115 there is more to be
done I'm here today to ask your support
for this important
bill recently I attended Jael car
committee meetings regarding updated
landfill
rules they concluded that the way to
create effective Solid Waste reform is
through legislative policy that is
exactly what HB 2115 would do in one
addressing the principle of net public
benefit two two further defining
capacity need and the timing to bring it
online and three clarifying that a
landfill permit must be evaluated on its
own merits separate from other
projects considering the concept of net
public benefit why wouldn't we look at
both the benefits and harms of a
landfill permit isn't it common sense to
weigh both the pluses and the minuses of
such an impactful project we all know
that landfill can have significant
detrimental repercussions for a region
the environment public health and for
communities it seems to me that making a
permanent decision is not just about
Capacity Analysis and meeting technical
regulations I support House Bill 215
because it includes a holistic set of
considerations and in the absence of
clearly articulated legislative policy
which we we are depending on you for
decisions are left to the discretion of
a single agency
Dees I do ask could the benefits versus
harms analysis that HB 2115
provides have made a difference in the
permitting process of St gobain in marac
which has been has had a devastating
impact on that
Community would such an analysis have
changed the results of any of the
state's 22 super fund
sites we will never know
that uh just to consider capacity why
would we ever permit additional capacity
if that capacity doesn't fill a demand
shortfall for more than half its
life and regarding a new landfill why
would we ever bring that additional
capacity online before it is
needed if Our intention is to achieve
de's Solid Waste Management plan with
the overarching goal of significantly
reducing the amount of solid waste
needing disposal in the state which was
a reduction of 25% by 2030 and
45% by
2050 then shouldn't we be measured and
prudent and how we bring on any
incremental capacity to paraphrase a
well-known state
if we build it the trash will come and
much of it may come from out of
state finally a landfill needs to be
evaluated on its own merits and
shouldn't be bundled with a carrot such
as a recycling
center House Bill 215 makes that
legislative
policy crystal
clear and I would just like to add by
the way
I'd like to address the fact that
testimony you no doubt receive um from
the waste industry over this
bill um in my
opinion unduly influences New
Hampshire's waste policy and has for
decades with what I perceive as
fear-mongering and speculation
I believe they do not have our best
interest at heart and I believe it is
time for the legislator to call this
out for what it is and Implement
protective
measures that New Hampshire citizens and
their environment need based on good
regulation not industry
speculation and I would like to ask
director whimet to try to make more to
think more outside of the box
of what is possible for net benefit
permitting for landfills we cannot keep
throwing up our hands in the air and
despair so thank you so much for giving
me this opportunity to speak to you and
uh thank you for your service to New
Hampshire thank you any
questions no okay thank you so much
after all that appreciate
it go ahead all
right I would love to thank you madam
chair I would love to know and thank you
for your testimony um I would love to
know if you are familiar with um
applications that are coming in with
other pieces of an app you know with
other pieces of making sweetening the
pot in a sense that's changing the
landscape and um and how that is should
never be involved in a in a you know in
this net public benefit you mean formula
you mean like the carrot thing correct
um I guess I the only one I am familiar
with is I believe cassella had offered
to um build a murf a materials recycling
center in uh Southern New
Hampshire um as a
carrot um that would help them to get
their landfill built in the North
Country um so that's a type that's
something spefic specific that I refer
to does that make sense yes thank you
representative K yes thank you madam
chair I just want to follow up on that
question so is it my understanding that
they won't build the recycling plant in
Southern New Hampshire unless they get
permitted is that what you're saying
that is my understanding um as a matter
of fact we were hoping that if the um
landfill permits were denied for the new
landfill in Northern New Hampshire and
Dalton maybe they would still build it
because they have had a center in
Bethlehem for over 30 years and maybe
the states earned it by by now but as
far as I understand um representative
it's tied to if they implemented a new
landfill in Dalton New Hampshire
speculation so followup thank you madam
chair so do you know this for a fact or
is this just speculation no no this is
what I've read in paperwork and
newspapers and all that for last couple
years as um cassella has hoped to build
a new facility in Dalton New Hampshire
this has been part of what they hoped
could go along with it and I think what
this Bill is saying is that any new
landfill and the permitting of one
really needs to be able to stand on
itself by
itself follow sure one more followup y
thank you I I
guess you read it in a newspaper well
I'm I'm part of ncbc I've been studying
right years but I guess my my my thing
is is from my own understanding I want
to make sure
that
without they won't build the recycling
plant is that correct I'm sorry say that
again please they will not build a
recycling plant
that's a known fact if they don't get
permitted is that is that is my
understanding and that could change and
maybe it has changed since I understood
that but that was my understanding okay
thank you okay thank you representative
H Haskins thank you madam chair is it
not our understanding that it's part of
the application for the permit you mean
that it it's made mention of in the
application I believe I I believe so
representative H Haskins thank you again
I I always want to be sure of what I say
I know um but I believe you are
right any other questions thank you very
much for coming this afternoon and
hanging in with us thank you so much uh
our last person I know um natch gra is
not here so I'm not going to call him
Michael Wright is our last pink card
anybody else have any other pink cards
you are the
last of the day thank you that that's
good for everybody since I was going to
say good morning as well too and it's
good afternoon um so I I just wanted to
mention before I start with my testimony
that um the tying between the recycle
center and the landfill is actually in
cela's application so it that that's
where it's located okay yeah uh so
anyhow my name is Michael right uh I'm a
North Country resident and I'm from
Littleton and I'm very pleased to be
here today to express my strong support
for the house bill uh 2115 which is a
common sense bill it just modernizes and
it up levels our land landfill permit
process and it requires applicants to uh
submit a comprehensive report outlining
their proposed projects potentials harms
and benefits which just makes
sense um I would imagine that uh you
wouldn't want to wake up every day to
the smell of rotting stench of um
decomposing waste that's what happens
with a lot of people around these
landfills and they have to get up and
they worry about their water and perhaps
worry about the traffic and if they're
if it's a tourist location like Northern
New Hampshire they're going to worry
about what type of of impression this
leaves on tourism so this is really
important that we actually you know take
a measured approach to considering the
harm that potentially might be incurred
by citing a landfill or in that case
even with you know depending upon the
specifics uh an extension of an ex of an
existing landfill that's out there I
think there's been some testimony that's
been submitted that I'd like that that
warrant some careful consideration
because I think there are some
weaknesses mischaracterization in this
and um there is testimony that suggests
that HP HB 215 duplicates existing
processes and adds unnecessary cost
I believe this is a
misrepresentation currently Dees
practices primarily focus on evaluating
the economic benefits such as job
creation and landfill capacity without
explicitly requiring a detailed
assessment of the potential harms like
groundwater contamination noise and air
pollution so HP 215 addresses this Gap
by ensuring there's a balance evaluation
of both benefits and harms this is not
redundancy it is a necessary enhan ment
to protect New Hampshire residents in
their
environment uh opponents argue that HB
uh 215 introduced subjectivity into the
permitting process in reality what HB
215 calls for harm assessments to be
conducted by independent and qualified
third parties ensuring
objectivity moreover adding a structured
appraisal of harms does not inherently
delay the process but ensures that
decisions are based upon a comprehensive
and fair
evaluations this approach prevents Rush
decisions that could lead to long-term
environmental and public health cost
everybody in new New Hampshire knows the
impact of this when we think of like the
St gobain
situation opponents will claim that HB
215 will increase costs for applicants
and harm lowincome
families however the cost of harm
assessment is modest it's very modest uh
to the total cost of landfill permitting
and
construction most importantly failing to
evaluate harms can result in a far
greater cost to communities in the form
of health issues property value declines
in the environmental degr uh degradation
costs that typically and disunat uh
affect low-income
families opponents assert that the
current DS regulations are sufficient to
protect the health and property and the
environment well this bill wouldn't be
in front of you if that were the case
and there's ample evidence around the
country we can take a look at some of
the landfills that are somewhat locally
here too where people have had to
actually sell their house because they
just couldn't take the odor any longer
and I I just can't imagine being in that
type of
position um opponents claim that the
bill creates an anti-pr bias by
requiring harm assessments while this is
completely unfounded HB 2115 simply
seeks to create a fair and objective
process applicants are already required
to promote the benefits of their
projects this bill ensures that
potential harms are also objectively
evaluated creating a balanced and
transparent uh permitting
framework in conclusion uh HB 2115
strengthens New Hampshire's uh landfill
permitting process by addressing
addressing critical gaps in evaluating
environmental and Community impacts I
would uh ask the committee to that we
don't let the pursuit of perfection or
the status quo getting way which could
be really important progress for our
landfill permitting process uh this bill
does not hinder um excuse me hinder
development but ensures that projects
are conducted responsibly safeguarding
public health and environment and with
that I urge you to consider the full
scope of the bill and its protections
offer to New Hampshire residents thank
you for your time thank you
representative wheeler you have a
question thank you madam chair just to
clarify your testimony sir
you're saying that this bill despite the
testimony of others brings objectivity
and fairness into this process which is
currently subjective exactly thank you
do you have written testimony I I do yes
and I I haven't had a chance to upload
it I will do that by the time I get to
my car make sure that our clerk uh
representative King okay gets it okay
we'll do thank you your copy would do as
well sure yeah I can leave you my copy
yeah thank you so much okay thank you
anybody any other
questions seeing none I'd like the blue
sheet
please and I'm going to close Madam
chair can I just read something into the
record real quick because it was based
upon a question sure okay so this is
directly pass the blue sheet please this
is directly from page 36 of the public
benefit application for cassella quotes
by permitting the GSL project Dees will
also be greenlighting the creation of a
new state-ofthe-art materials recycling
facility in Southern New Hampshire end
quote okay thank
you okay so we have on the blue sheet
here um six
people uh supporting this bill and zero
people
against and on our online um portal we
have 69 persons registering their
support and four registering
opposition with that I want to close the
hearing for HB I'm sorry close the
hearing for HB
215 and I'd like to hear a motion to
adjourn for today so moved any second
thank you um all those in favor I anyone
oppos thank you very much we will see
you next Tuesday
at 10:00 a.m. we will have a a public
hearing on one of our other early bills
and afterwards we will have a work
session on all of the bills that we've
heard and likely have uh additional
hearings in the afternoon for bills I
don't know yet but I will they will be
announced thank you very much another
land bill
right and I want to thank you all for
your wrapped attention and um everybody
who attended today for hanging in so
late we really appreciate your time I
didn't say you